Hast du dein Handy ausgemacht?
Wie oft denn jetzt noch?
Ich mach mein Handy nicht aus.
Mein Handy ist immer lautlos.
Ja, bei mir auch. Meine Eltern beschweren sich ständig, dass sie mich nie erreichen.
Hä?
Weil ich nie mitbekomme, dass mich jemand anruft.
Ich meine, man hat sich irgendwie angewöhnt,
dass man ständig auf sein Telefon guckt
und dann kriegt man halt mit, dass vor drei Minuten jemand einen angerufen hat.
Und dann ruft man halt zurück.
Aber da haben die Leute halt schon 30 Sekunden gewartet,
dass es piept, ne?
Okay, mein Handy ist nicht auf lautlos,
mein Handy ist immer auf Vibration, sagen wir es so.
Also ich krieg's mit, wenn jemand anruft.
Außerdem vibriert auch das Ding an meinem Arm.
Und dann sehe ich, wer dran geht.
Aber wenn du hier rangehst, dann redest du über das Ding.
Und das ist dumm.
Deine Apple Watch meinst du?
Ja, der hat das gelandet.
Hast du mal Nightrider geguckt?
Eigentlich ist extrem viel aus dieser Serie
schon wahr geworden.
Also ich weiß nicht,
diese Afrofrisuren
bei weißen Leuten kommen wahrscheinlich nie zurück.
Aber,
dass du
über deine Armbanduhr dein Auto
anrufst und dein Auto mit dir spricht
und dann du
wie Michael Knight sagen kannst,
Kid, fahr vor und dann fährt das Auto von alleine
vor die Eingangstür und holt dich dort ab.
Das ist ja schon ohne weiteres möglich.
Prinzipiell.
Wenn das hätte gehen können, dann hätte sich
vielleicht mein Auto von alleine bei mir gemeldet, dass der Bus
das gestriffen hat.
Willkommen bei Akronomisierbuch, dem Techbuch-Empfehlungspodcast.
Ich verstehe, was du meinst.
Wir haben jetzt Feedback bekommen, nachdem wir das letzte Mal einen Haufen Bücher empfohlen
hatten, dass wir ein ganz wichtiges vergessen haben.
Nämlich?
Nämlich das Haskell-Book.
Uh, stimmt. Haskellbook.com.
Ich habe Podcast-Feedback über Signal
bekommen vom
Pharao. Der hat geschrieben,
empfehle doch mal das Haskellbook.
Du hörst es. Ich habe es empfohlen.
Ist das gut? Ich glaube, es ist gut.
Es ist ein gewaltig langes Buch
und redet sehr viel über Typ Theorie
und über die Sprache selber.
Kann man durchaus mal lesen.
Wenn du jetzt Ambitionen hast,
tatsächlich Haskell zu machen.
Ich habe Ambitionen, mit Haskell was zu machen.
und wollte immer mal einen guten Einstieg finden,
aber dieses Buch steht ja schon länger auf meiner Liste,
dass ich da mal reinschauen möchte,
beziehungsweise mal kaufen möchte und mal reinschauen möchte.
Ja, also wenn du es unbedingt kaufen möchtest,
dann sag doch mal Bescheid,
dann kann ich es dir vielleicht kaufen.
Interesse sei hiermit bekundet.
Ja, ansonsten haben wir noch anderes Feedback bekommen vom letzten Mal.
Wir haben eine Mail bekommen von dem MCN oder Magnesium,
Magnesium, wie auch immer,
der genannt werden möchte.
und zwar hatten wir ja kurz drüber gesprochen, dass
PIVIC, nicht mehr PIVIC heißt, sondern Matomo
Sonst ändert sich nichts
Dieses Rider-Framework kannst du jetzt
Matomo kannst du jetzt benutzen
als Matomo
und wir haben es bloß mal kurz angeschnitten
und sind nicht wirklich auf die Hintergründe
eingegangen und das ist wohl ein bisschen mehr
ein kleinerer Clusterfuck, als wir
gedacht hatten
Ich hab's mal kurz reingeschaut, ich hab's auch ehrlich gesagt
nicht hundertprozentig verstanden
aber PIVIC hat sich wohl schon vor langer Zeit
aufgesplittet in PIVIC und PIVIC Pro.
Das hatte ich glaube ich noch mitbekommen, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, wann das war. Okay, ich habe es wahrscheinlich eben gelesen,
aber wieder vergessen, irgendwie 15
irgendwann rum, kann das sein? Ich glaube, zu dem
Zeitpunkt hat sich auch mal ganz kurz ein PIVIC aufgesetzt.
Okay. Und
dachte mir dann,
nee, ich bleibe mal bei dem normalen PIVIC, ja.
Ja, okay, aber
da gab es wohl auch echt Probleme
und also prinzipiell war das
ja das Gleiche und die haben sich auch gegenseitig endorsed
gehabt, bis da irgendwo Kommunikation
so dermaßen gefällt ist, dass dem nicht mehr so war.
aber warum genau PIVIC jetzt Matomo heißt
und PIVIC Pro nach wie vor PIVIC Pro
habe ich echt nicht verstanden
aber auf jeden Fall kann man da gerne mal ein bisschen nachforschen
das ist wohl noch viel weirder
als man gedacht hat
wie sich Leute immer um Namen so streiten
aber ich meine das machst du ja einfach nicht
einfach so, du hast deinen Namen seit Jahren
für so ein Projekt, den gibst du doch nicht einfach so her
da verlierst du doch quasi die komplette Brand Recognition
um dieses Bullshit-Wort mal aufzugreifen
Naja, Brand Recognition ist aber auch was, was du vielleicht nicht mehr haben möchtest. Manchmal ändern ja Firmen auch einfach so ihren Namen, weil ihre Marke verbrannt ist. So wie hier diese, ich weiß gar nicht welcher Energieanbieter das neulich war, der vor ein, zwei Jahren sein. Die haben einfach gesagt, okay, wir machen jetzt alles neu.
Da gab es diese Bullshit-Werbung, wo du überhaupt nicht wusstest, von wem das war.
Genau, und im Endeffekt haben die sich einfach bloß umbenannt, weil sie unbeliebt waren, weil sie ja noch Atomkraftwerke betreiben und so weiter.
und so fort. Gibt es überhaupt einen bediebten Energieanbieter?
Nein.
Also ich würde mich auch nicht wundern, wenn sich
Facebook irgendwie nächstes Jahr umbenennt und dann
irgendwie, das wäre krass.
Irgendwie spiked gerade so
einen Facebook-Hate.
So eine Liste von Blog-Posts,
wie lösche ich meinen
Facebook-Account am besten.
Ich habe es auch eine Weile gemacht.
Viel zu spät meiner Meinung nach.
Gibt es einen Ersatz für diese
lokale Veranstaltungsempfehlung?
Aber brauche ich auch nicht. Also ich habe vor
zwei Jahren mal so einen lustlosen kleinen Blogpost
geschrieben von wegen Unquitting Facebook.
Von wegen, was mir fehlen würde.
Blog.Killian.
Der ist jetzt nicht so richtig gut.
Und damals habe ich Facebook eigentlich
nur benutzt hin und wieder mal für den Messenger und
vor allem für dieses Groups Feature,
weil die Cocoa Heads Dresden hauptsächlich darüber
kommunizieren, was mich sehr stört. Ja, ich glaube,
das hat man schon mal gehabt.
Akronomisierbar berichtete. Aber ich habe da
seit dem letzten Jahr
mindestens Facebook vielleicht
insgesamt zwei, drei Mal offen gehabt.
um einfach nur eigentlich zu schauen, ob meine Privacy-Stellungen
auch wirklich so Lockdown sind, wie ich hoffe.
Und vor einer Weile
habe ich dann mich entschlossen, einfach mal das Indie-Account komplett
zu löschen. Also nicht nur zu deaktivieren, sondern
die Löschung zu beantragen, was wahrscheinlich
darin endet, dass das Deleted-Flag jetzt gesetzt
ist und es einfach alles private gestaltet.
Aber GDPR kommt ja jetzt in einem Monat.
Da kann ich es mal anfragen. Was gab denn hier noch
so an Daten? Das ist auch was, was
die Firma tatsächlich bewegt. Kann ich das eigentlich
anfragen ohne einen Account zu haben? Ich meine, die haben ja Daten von mir.
Also müsste ich rechtlich ja dazu in der Lage sein, anzufragen
irgendwie. Ja, es gibt halt auch
viele Firmen, die dann einfach sagen, gut, okay, dann
hören wir jetzt halt auf, Daten zu speichern, was auch eine schöne
Sache ist. Finde ich gut, genau das will ich ja eigentlich.
Du bist im Fall von Facebook.
Ja, bei Facebook würdest du das wahrscheinlich nicht machen.
Oh, ich sehe gerade, wo ich zum ersten Mal überhaupt in deinen
Blog reingucke, 8. April 2017,
akronomisierbar.
Ja, ich habe einmal damals...
Mein Blog ist auf Englisch, ich kann nicht
auf Deutsch schreiben.
Ich habe auch meinen Blog irgendwie auf Englisch,
aber da habe ich bestimmt auch seit zwei
acronymizable.
Jetzt liegt es nicht diesem scheiß Post,
der ist auch nicht qualitativ hochwertig, so wie alles
auf dieser Seite. Gut, okay,
lassen wir das alles sein.
Oh Mann.
Nee, aber so viel erstmal zum
Follow-Up. Nee, was haben wir noch im Follow-Up?
Und zwar hatte ich ja letztes Mal über
Wit.ai gesprochen, diesen netten
Natural Language Understanding Service.
Das war das von Facebook? Genau.
Wie mir zu dem Zeitpunkt noch
passender Übergang eigentlich. Zu dem Zeitpunkt
war es mir noch nicht hundertprozentig klar.
aber das ist ja anscheinend wirklich die Engine,
die Facebook nutzt, um
Natural Language Understanding oder
also NLU zu machen.
Auf Text
in jeglicher Form.
Da hat ja irgendwie jeder große Anbieter seine eigene
Plattform. Bei Facebook ist es eben WIT AI, was die
gekauft haben. Bei Google habe ich den Namen schon wieder vergessen.
Bei Microsoft ist es das Lui AI.
Amazon hat Amazon Lex,
genau, da hat auch der Name Alexa.
A, Lex.
Das von Apple ist ja jedenfalls,
Also die Siri-APIs kann man ja auf den Apple-Plattformen auch nutzen,
aber das ist ja jetzt nichts Öffentliches, wo man irgendwie
mit PAS ansprechen kann.
Und
also WID-AI ist tatsächlich das,
was Facebook dafür alles nutzt. Und das ist auch, wie gesagt,
immer noch ganz cool. WID-AI ist eine
coole Plattform, kann man was mit machen. Man kann auch mit den anderen
was machen. Mittlerweile habe ich auch mit allen anderen mal rumgespielt.
Außerdem von Microsoft,
weil ich komme einfach
nicht klar mit Web-Interfaces von Microsoft-Produkten.
Du blickst ums Verrecken.
Ich dachte schon, AWS war kompliziert,
als ich das erste Mal durchsteigen wollte.
aber Microsoft legt ihm ja noch eine
Krone oben drauf, so ein Sahnehäubchen
du meldest dich an, du hast keine Ahnung
was du eigentlich tust
und das Beste, nachdem ich mich dafür
angemeldet habe und überhaupt keinen
blassen Schimmer hatte, was ich getan habe
und irgendwie ein Testaccount für irgendwas hatte
für einen Monat, am nächsten Tag ruft mich
jemand von Microsoft aus München an
und fragt, wie ich mit dem Produkt
zurechtkomme und ob ich Fragen habe
und ich soll mich bitte melden, wenn ich Probleme habe
ruft mich an
Ich bin rangegangen, weil ich
nur mal aus München, ja keine Ahnung, ich kenne Leute
in München, wer ist denn das? Ja, hier ist Microsoft
Service, wir quatschen
über ihren Test-Account.
Was?
Das ist doch mal, also...
Mit Mail zu spammen, so wie alle anderen auch.
Naja, die machen halt noch
persönlichen, menschlichen Kontakt.
Ja, das war sehr eng.
Habe ich die Geschichte mal erzählt, wie ich irgendwie als 14-Jähriger
meine erste Homepage gehostet habe.
Und das wohlbekommen.
Nee, aber ich habe mich dann irgendwann,
wie hieß die Suchmaschine von Microsoft damals?
MSN? MSDN?
Einen von den beiden.
Ich glaube MSN.
Da habe ich mal dort gesucht und da war tatsächlich,
da hatte irgendjemand handgeschriebene Rezension
zu meiner Webseite geschrieben.
Das war ziemlich witzig.
Hendrik geht zur großen Schule, spielt Klappe.
Das mag diese Musik.
Ach, das ist aber nett.
Das ist ja geil.
Warum ist sowas jetzt?
Das gibt es jetzt auch.
Das wird dann bloß von irgendeiner AI geschrieben.
Hoffentlich nicht von Microsoft
Stay AI.
Sonst hast du irgendwie ein Hate Speech zu deiner Seite.
Ich habe jetzt kurz überlegt, ob ich so eine Geschichte,
ob ich jetzt simuliere, was da für ein Text stehen würde,
aber ich glaube, das würde das Rating unseres Podcasts spontan
irgendwie um ein paar Jahre umsetzen.
Nee, aber ich habe mich auf jeden Fall mit diesen ganzen Plattformen auseinandergesetzt
und prinzipiell funktionieren die alle gleich.
Also du gibst irgendwie deine Daten an, markierst dir halt deinen Text.
Also du schreibst erstmal so eine, du hast mir das das letzte Mal erklärt,
du schreibst irgendwie so eine Liste an.
Genau, ich habe dafür...
Beispielsätzen auf, markierst da Schlüsselwörter drin,
trainierst irgendein Netz an und dann
kriegst du quasi, wenn du einen Satz natürlich in die Sprache
reinschmeißt, kriegst du irgendwie so einen Intent-Datenblock
raus oder so. Exakt, also du kriegst halt
irgendwie, was auch immer du raushaben möchtest,
also die meisten nutzen da entweder
irgendwelche Intents oder Sentiments, die man da
versucht rauszuziehen, aber im Prinzip bedeutet
das alles das Gleiche, weil die Plattformen sind alle darauf ausgelegt,
dass du irgendwie von der
Idee her so eine Chat-
Interface betreiben kannst.
Ob das jetzt wirklich explizit ein Chat-Interface ist
oder ein Assistent auf irgendeiner anderen Ebene,
aber die sind alle in diese Richtung ausgelegt.
Das heißt, irgendjemand gibt dir ein kurzes Text-Schnipsel mit einer Absicht oder irgendwas, was er getan haben möchte.
Und du versuchst zu verstehen, was ist der Intent und was sind die einzelnen, nennen wir sie Entities,
die heißen auch auf allen Plattformen anders, die du da rausziehen möchtest.
Also keine Ahnung, stell dir einen Timer auf 12 Uhr, dann willst du rausziehen, ah, das ist ein Intent für neuen Timer.
Timer auf 12 Uhr gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, aber Timer auf 12 Minuten oder sowas.
Und du zerstörst dann raus, ah, 12 Minuten, das ist eine Zeitangabe, Minuten, Minuteneinheit und 12, genau.
Und versuchst halt sowas da rauszuziehen.
und worüber ich letztens gestolpert bin,
ist ein relativ neues
Ding, das nennt sich Snips.ai
und die sind,
finden es kacke, dass es diese ganze Plattform gibt
und die alle in der Cloud laufen,
bei jedem großen Anbieter.
Haben die nicht ihren eigenen Cloud-Dienst auch noch am Laufen?
Die haben keinen, also prinzipiell keinen Cloud-Dienst
haben die am Laufen, die haben eine Webseite, wo du
in der GUI Dinge machen kannst, aber
was die machen, ist, die sind der
festen Überzeugung, dass das ganze Zeug lokal
laufen müsste und zwar der ganze Stack davon,
Nicht nur die NLU-Engine, sondern auch die Automatic Speech Recognition.
Also Sprache zu Text und Text zu Intent.
Diese zwei Schritte sollen komplett lokal laufen.
Und die haben da eine Plattform für hochgezogen.
Also wie gesagt, keine Plattform, sondern die haben eine Seite.
Du kannst ja auf deren Seite deine Beispielchampel eintragen.
Sagen, welche Sprache soll das?
Für die Automatic Speech Recognition unterstützen sie aktuell auch kein Deutsch.
Aber das ist für meinen Anwendungsfall noch nicht so relevant,
weil ich generell nur an einem textbasierten Interface interessiert bin.
Kommt aber bald.
Und diese NLU-Engine funktioniert richtig gut.
Du kannst, wie gesagt, wer besser antrainieren,
kannst dir den fertig trainierten Assistenten runterladen.
Das ist einfach nur ein JSON-Paket, wo quasi alles drinsteht.
Das ist auch nicht quasi wirklich was Trainiertes,
sondern das sind einfach nur die Examples in deren Format gepackagt,
wie es deren Software dann lokal wieder versteht.
Und kannst dann lokal das Tool nutzen, was diese JSON reinfüttert,
trainiert sich innerhalb von ein paar Sekunden, je nach Datenmenge.
Aber ich habe da relativ viel mittlerweile drin.
Also ich behaupte, dass es relativ viel sieht aus nach einer guten Menge,
funktioniert auch echt ganz gut und es geht in ein paar
Sekunden durch und danach kannst du
deinen Textbaustein hinwerfen, das wird komplett
lokal auseinandergenommen und das
funktioniert richtig, richtig, richtig gut.
Die haben da auch ein bisschen drüber geblockt, lohnt sich
auf jeden Fall mal anzuschauen, auch deren Blog, auch wenn es leider
ein Medium-Blog ist, was ich immer ein bisschen knacker finde.
Da können wir vielleicht irgendwo mal eingehen
drauf. Genau, es ist so
Medium von der Qualität der Seite her, aber
der Blog ist cool
und die schreiben so ein bisschen
über Benchmarking, was sie gemacht haben
und wie genau das aussieht, wie sie diesen Assistenten trainieren.
Also ich kenne mich mit dem ML-Background da jetzt nicht ganz so gut aus.
Manche von unseren Hörern bestimmen viel mehr und können sich damit auch mal auseinandersetzen.
Wenn ihr wiederholender Hörer von Akronomisierbar seid und euch mit Machine Learning auskennt,
dann sagt doch mal bitte Bescheid, wir würden uns jetzt gerne mit euch unterhalten.
Generell.
Nee, aber die sind der Meinung, dass das sehr, sehr performant läuft verglichen mit vielen anderen Sachen.
Und zusätzlich ist der Bonus natürlich noch,
dass das eben kein Replicas machen muss.
Und das ist natürlich mit Abspann das Langsamste noch, was dazukommt.
Und wenn man das auch noch außen vor lässt,
dann läuft das richtig, richtig, richtig schnell.
Und zwar, ich glaube, die Zahlen, die ich im Kopf habe,
so noch auf dem aktuellen MacBook,
die haben da so Beispiele für so einen Weather-Intent, glaube ich,
kriegst du in einer Millisekunde alles gepasst.
Und auf einem Pi Zero, aus einem Raspi Zero,
das ist ja auch echt so die Low-Level-Hardware,
die man da noch mit hinschmeißen kann,
läuft aber auch in 200 Millisekunden durch.
für Nutzer sind 200 Millisekunden immer noch
voll okay. Du machst sowas nicht on scale
für tausende Leute auf einem Device,
sondern prinzipiell dann halt,
also worauf die halt abziehen, ist, dass
du so ein Home Assistant auf Raspi-Basis dir selber
hinstellst und der dann so eine Hotword Detection
macht, das heißt du sagst irgendwie, hey, Snips in den Raum
und der erkennt das und dann
stellst du deine Query und das wird dann halt
komplett lokal auseinandergenommen und nur der Request für
wenn, keine Ahnung, Wetterdaten gefetched werden müssen,
das wird dann halt abgeschickt, aber
ansonsten gehört halt nichts, das Internet davon,
nichts. Aber
jetzt nochmal, das wirft jetzt die Frage bei mir auf,
dass wenn ich mir damit jetzt meinen eigenen
Homegrown
Voice-Assistenten bauen möchte,
dann bringt mir das wirklich
bloß die Spracherkennung
und die
Intent Recognition, aber
jetzt den tatsächlichen Assistenten
muss ich schon noch selber bauen oder gibt es
da eine Plattform, wo ich so wie bei
Alexa so Skills beschreiben kann?
Das ist eine gute Frage, das habe ich tatsächlich in
deren Discord, die machen halt über Discord,
mal nachgehakt, weil ich genau das auch nicht ganz
verstanden hatte. Im Prinzip kriegst du ja, wie gesagt,
ein Intent, wie du schon richtig meins draus.
Die kam eine Liste von Community-Scripts,
soweit ich das verstanden habe. Und das baut alles auf diesem
Home Assistant. Das ist auch ein cooles Tool.
Können wir mit in die Show-Notes mit reinpacken.
Ich glaube, Home Assistant hat sogar einen Podcast.
Oha, das wusste ich gar nicht.
Wenn es das gleiche ist, woran ich gerade denke,
müssen wir mal nachdenken. Und darauf baut das alles auf
und das nutzt das mit. Und da kannst du dir
für bestehende Dinge
alles mit reinladen.
für zum Beispiel diesen DVB-VVO
Intent-Parser, den ich da noch mit
reingepflanscht habe, was ich da nutzen möchte
für meinen Telegram-Bot und für was anderes,
was ich gerade versuche zu bauen.
Da gibt es natürlich nichts vorgebaut.
Das übernehme ich dann mit.
Aber das habe ich ja eh schon auf anderer Seite
immer wieder gebaut. Das ist ja kein Problem.
Aber klar, sowas muss natürlich auch mit ran.
Muss man die Intents...
Ach nee, das hängt jetzt wieder mit dem Assistant zusammen.
Was mich bei... Ich hatte ja jetzt mal eine Zeit lang
in Alexa, in Amazon Echo rumstehen.
das habe ich jetzt meinen Eltern vermacht,
was mich da genervt hat, wenn du so
bestimmte Skills installiert hast, zum Beispiel
Chefkoch oder Podcasts
oder sowas, das hat ja
meistens nicht von alleine funktioniert.
Du hast dann gesagt,
hey Alexa,
mal schauen, bei wie vielen Zuhörern das jetzt nicht was auslässt.
Hey Alexa, frag
Chefkoch, wie ich so und so mache.
Oder frag Podcasts
nach, so und so hast du häufig gehabt.
Oder manchmal hast du ein Skill hinzugefügt,
dann hat dir erstmal, wie in so einem
Telefonmenü gewesen, dann hat Alexa plötzlich
erstmal angefangen, dir
das Hauptmenü von unserem Skill vorzulesen
und dir das zu erklären. Brauchst du natürlich irgendwie,
weil du hast ja sonst keinerlei Angaben, wie das
Ding funktioniert. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so,
als ob sich das wirklich so anfühlt, wie so ein
Star Trek Computer, dem du einfach irgendwas Grobes sagst,
was du gerne haben möchtest.
Ich hab mich schon richtig schwarz
geärgert, wenn ich irgendwie fünfmal versucht habe,
Alexa was zu erklären, was ich hören
möchte. Das hat nie richtig funktioniert.
Das war dein Beispiel mit Alexa, mal Spiel weiter?
Ja, Spiel weiter. Und dann kam
Das Leben geht weiter von Rosenstolz.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, Alexa, stopp.
Dann musst du fünfmal sagen, Alexa, stopp.
Und dann kommst du dir irgendwie ein Depp vor, weil du dich einfach Stopp sagen kannst oder sowas.
Dann musst du immer Alexa anfangen.
Und dann sagst du, Alexa, das war falsch.
Und dann kommt sowas wie, vielen Dank für dein Feedback.
Oder wenn du dann sagst, Alexa, spiel nie wieder Rosenstolz.
Und dann kommt, spiele nie wieder von Rosenstolz.
Nee, also von wahrer AI sind wir echt noch weit entfernt.
Also so dumme Sprachassistenten, die halt auf die dümmsten Queries,
beziehungsweise musst du halt wirklich, also bei Siri fällt das immer noch ein bisschen besser auf,
weil ich hasse es, auf Siri so rumzuhaten prinzipiell,
aber es ist allgemein bekannt, das ist echt ein bisschen hinterher.
Aber du lernst halt auch irgendwann, also du musst dich halt der Plattform anpassen.
Du lernst irgendwann echt gut, wie du deine Queries formulieren musst,
damit generell Sprachassistenten verstehen, was du von denen möchtest.
Und das finde ich ehrlich gesagt kacke.
Also hier ein Kumpel von mir freut sich total,
dass seine kleine Tochter jetzt mit dem Ding redet,
weil er auch so ein Echo zu Hause hat.
Ich glaube, ich weiß gar nicht, wie intensiv
sie das macht, aber irgendwie nachher gewöhnt
sich die kleine so eine Sprache
an, damit sie irgendwie...
Nee, das glaube ich nicht.
Aber eigentlich ist es falsch, dass du dich der Maschine
anpasst in der Art und Weise, wie du Sprache verwendest.
Im Prinzip haben wir es doch bisher auch so gemacht.
Aber ich bin absolut
ein Freund davon, dass wir irgendwann schlauere AI
haben, ganz klar. Der John Syracuse
von dem ATP-Podcast... Obwohl es schon ganz schön gruselig
wäre ehrlich gesagt, wenn du wirklich nicht mehr erkennst,
dass da kein bezahlter Mensch dahinter hängt.
Darum geht es doch aber gerade. Da wollen wir doch hin.
Ich meine, das ist doch gerade der Sinn,
warum man diesen Assistenten haben möchte.
Im Prinzip will doch jeder quasi
einen cheap persönlichen
Secretary haben, der halt
billig ist im Sinne von, kostet 60 Euro
und eine Anschaffung, stellst du daheim hin und das war's.
Und musst nie wieder Gehalt essen, sonst was zahlen.
Okay, Essen zahlen ist ein bisschen komisch,
aber du musst nie Gehalt zahlen.
Oder dass die Assistent manchmal nicht da ist.
Das meine ich eigentlich damit, genau, danke.
der ist halt einfach billig und da
und da wollen wir halt hin
also da wollen die meisten Leute hin, sicherlich nicht jeder
aber da wollen diese Homeassistants auch irgendwann hin
und klar müssen wir durch viele lange
Jahre der Schmerzen erstmal da durch
bevor wir irgendwo sinnvoll ankommen
aber vielleicht schaffen wir es ja nicht
dann haben wir wieder eine Berufsgruppe überflüssig gemacht
aber das ist doch gut
also ich meine, ja
immer wieder Leute, die mit diesem Argument kommen von wegen
also das stelle ich nicht dir, aber
gibt es immer wieder diese Argumente von wegen, ja aber es ist doch kacke
wenn wir Leuten ihre Jobs überflüssig machen
das passiert schon immer und das wird auch immer weiter passieren
das ist gut, wenn wir irgendwann
an den Punkt kommen, wo man Dinge, die
kein Mensch machen muss, einfach Menschen nicht
machen müssen und wenn wir irgendwann an den Punkt kommen
wo Menschen nicht arbeiten müssen
sondern einfach sich frei entfalten können, wie sie
lustig sind und der Rest von selber
funktioniert, das ist doch wunderbar, das ist ein tropischer Traum
den Arbeitsstand des Feldarbeiters
überflüssig gemacht haben
das stimmt
oder keine Ahnung, Kutscher
Busfahrer
aber der Busfahrer ist der Nächste
jetzt fahren hier schon autonome
Nahverkehrsfahrzeuge. Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ich meine, viele Leute behaupten auch immer, selbst fahren Autos,
dauern noch ewig, aber ich schalte mal zum Beispiel
so etwas wie Straßenbahn. Das lässt sich sowas von
an. Das können wir jetzt schon mit aktueller Technologie
komplett ersetzen, dass da jemand drin sitzen
muss. Ich hatte heute früh eine schöne Situation.
Ich war auf dem Weg zur Arbeit
und treffe da eine Freundin
auf dem Weg zur... Also ich stehe
in der Straßenbahn und ich sehe die irgendwie von außen einsteigen
mit so einem riesen Karton.
Und ich habe ihr dann ein bisschen
geholfen, das Ding von einer Straßenbahn in die nächste
zu transportieren. Und musste dann,
weil ich ihr das dann irgendwann komplett abgenommen hatte,
ist sie quasi vorgelaufen, hat die Tür von der nächsten
Straßenbahn aufgehalten und ich bin mit diesem
Riedkarton, den sie dann zurück zur Post bringen
wollte, weil er nicht in die Parkstation gepasst hat,
zu dieser
Acht dann hinlaufen.
Sie hat die Tür aufgehalten und als wir eingestiegen waren,
sehen wir, dass der Straßenbahnfahrer
ausgestiegen ist
und uns belegt hat.
Oh, zu groß muss der eigentlichen Tick kommen?
Nein, weil wir die Tür aufgehalten haben.
Also wenn ihr nochmal die Tür aufhalten wollt,
dann drückt ihr bitte hier diesen Knopf,
der ist für Rollstuhlfahrer da
und dann bleibt die Tür offen und dann könnt ihr auch,
weil wenn ihr die hier einfach so mit Kraft,
dann geht die vielleicht nachher kaputt und dann steige ich auch.
Aber ich gehe da hier in Dresden.
Okay, krass, ich dachte,
ich wette, wenn ich diesen Knopf jemals drücken sollte,
steigt der Straßenbahnfahrer aus
und sagt, hast du einen Rollstuhl oder was?
Oh Mann.
Ich habe jetzt, wo du es sagst,
ich glaube, ich bin letztens noch an der Straßenbahn gewesen
und da wollte der Straßenbahnfahrer,
da hat er sich jemanden rausschmeißen,
weil der angeblich die Tür kaputt gemacht hat.
Die fuhren auch nicht mehr weiter erstmal ein paar Minuten.
Die Tür ging auch nur noch durch seine Hilfe zu,
dem Straßenbahnführer.
Und die hat an der nächsten Haltestelle
später auch nicht mehr aufgemacht.
Die war kaputt.
Die Tür war kaputt.
Gut, okay, das hört man häufiger.
Da ist dann so ein ganzes Abteil von so einer Bahn
dann teilweise gesperrt,
weil die Tür defekt ist oder sowas.
Ja, aber in der Straßenbahn noch nicht.
Also eigentlich fahren die auch keine wirklichen Abteile.
Da kommt dann so ein Technikers-Informiert-Schild dran.
Apropos Straßenbahn.
Auf dem Weg vorhin hier gerade.
Ich hoffe ja, er ist ein Hörer von uns.
Das wäre super witzig.
Wir haben uns auf dem Weg zu Hendrik, wo wir gerade sitzen, getroffen gehabt schon.
Und in der Bahn einfach über random Kram und in dem Fall Linux-Distros gelabert.
Ich habe erzählt, dass ich mir auf Arbeit jetzt endlich meinen Arbeitsrechner mit Arch Linux installiert habe.
Und dann haben wir über Linux-Distros geredet.
Und dann habe ich generell über meine Liebe zu Ubuntu, hate me if you want to, aber e-mailt mich nicht deswegen, gesprochen.
Und plötzlich dreht sich jemand vor uns um und so, aber Debian!
Entschuldigung, darf ich euch mal kurz unterbrechen? Nehm doch einfach Debian.
Fand ich super geil,
wie da nie in der Bahn
auf Random Distro Gespräche
angesprochen wurde.
Fand ich cool.
Also ich mag den Typen,
der war mir sympathisch.
Der Typ, ja.
Ich hab mir leider sein,
ich hab ihn gar nicht im,
er saß hinter mir,
ich hab sein Gesicht gar nicht gesehen.
Das wäre so cool,
wenn der Hörer von uns ist.
Falls ja, bitte melde dich.
Ich fand das super cool.
Lass uns doch mal eine Folge
über Debian machen.
Nein.
Ich würde öfter in der Bahn
auf Random Distro
angesprochen werden,
das wäre fändisch cool.
Ich versuche manchmal,
wenn ich in einer größeren Gruppe
unterwegs bin,
so mit zwei, drei Leuten und mich in der Bahn mit denen
unterhalte und du wirst eine längere
Fahrt, so wie einmal quer durch die Stadt,
hast du ja manchmal, so gerade wenn du aus der Kneipe zurückkommst,
da habe ich es schon ein, zwei Mal gemacht, dass ich einfach
die Leute, die links und rechts von uns saßen, einfach so ins Gespräch
involviert habe, war irgendwas,
dann trete ich mich zu dem Typen, der eh die ganze Zeit garantiert
zuhört, du hast ein Gespräch mit drei Leuten, sitzen drei
andere drumherum, die hören eh zu.
Da kannst du auch sagen, wie ist das bei dir so?
Das ist erstmal so diese Schranke
durchbrochen und die dann so,
dann fängst du plötzlich an mit Leuten zu reden
und verabschiedest du dich für den Aussteigsten,
das finde ich eigentlich total cool, ich mache das gerne.
Ich habe das geschafft, wenn dann nur
spätabends oder so, die Leute generell,
also wenn du mit Gleichgesinnten quasi unterwegs bist,
die auch gerade aus der... Oder wenn du über Linux-Distributionen
redest. Oder das natürlich, ich fand's toll.
Hat Spaß gemacht.
Zumindest war ich froh,
dass ich es geschafft habe, mal wieder so ein Arch Linux
zu installieren. Ich war kurz davor,
zu Antergos oder sowas zu greifen,
was quasi... Was ist das denn? Das geht gar nicht.
Das ist ein Arch mit einem Installer,
also im Endeffekt unterscheidet es sich von einem normalen Arch
außer, dass du ein bisschen anderes Branding hast.
Ein Installer und noch ein, zwei
Paketquellen mehr.
Okay, also ähnlich wie Manjaro.
Manjaro, ja, und sowas, genau.
Aber im Endeffekt ist
Arch-Thielungsinstallieren super einfach.
Es geht.
An dem Gentoo bin ich selber gescheitert.
Nee, also da gibt es mal einen Installationsguide.
Das Wiki ist auch klasse.
Das Wiki ist super.
Ich habe mich manchmal auf DuckDuckGo fast gefilterbabbelt gefühlt,
weil wenn ich irgendwas Linux-relatedes gesucht habe,
habe ich immer als erstes das Arch-Thiel-Wiki gefunden.
Aber im Endeffekt ist es, du machst dir diesen Stick,
dann bootest du von dem Stick,
dann formatierst du deine Festplatte,
dann mountest du die Festplatte
in deinem Live-System nach MNT,
dann gibt es ein Kommando, das heißt
gen fstab, dann schreibst du das dorthin,
dann machst du ein
Change-Root dorthin
quasi, dann bist du quasi auf dem
System,
oder nee, du machst erst so ein Pack-Strap,
so Bootstrap, wo du irgendwie ein Standardsystem
dorthin kopierst, dann change-Root
bootest du dich dahin und dann bist du quasi gebootet
mit dem
Root auf dem bereits zu installierenden
System und dann fängst du einfach an, Pakete zu installieren.
Cool. Also,
Hendrik erklärt
auf the top of his head, wie man Arch installiert.
Ja, super einfach.
Passt.
Ich habe hinterher noch irgendwie
einen Halbtag gebraucht, um die restlichen Pakete zu installieren,
die mir noch gefehlt haben.
Und unser System auf Arbeit
kann ich damit heute noch nicht bauen nach drei Tagen, aber
das ist ja eine andere Komplexitätsstufe.
das System selber zu installieren, ist super einfach.
Okay. Das ist auch gut, witzig.
Wenn man sich traut und wenn man das alles schon mal gesehen hat,
also wenn man sich jetzt keine Angst davor hat, irgendwie mal
hier Gen Local oder sowas,
oder Hostname,
etc Hostname zu bearbeiten oder sowas.
So.
Schreibst du gerade die Shownotes?
Ich tippe immer mal live was dazu,
wenn wir was geschrieben haben, wenn wir was gesagt haben, ja.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Über was wollen wir heute reden?
Haben wir irgendwelche krassen Themen?
irgendwas passiert in der Welt aktuell?
Ich kann mir gerade
sowas erzählen, dass ich ein bisschen unter der Welt unterwegs war.
Stimmt, du hast Reiseerfahrung.
So ein bisschen, ganz wenig.
Ja, ich war jetzt drei Wochen in Kalifornien.
Stark?
Wieso?
Nee, es war einfach eine Dienstreise.
Ich arbeite für eine Firma
und wir haben ein Büro dort
und war ich mit den Leuten,
die in dem, also dort heißt
in Santa Barbara
und weil ich mit den Leuten dort auch relativ viel zu tun habe,
bin ich da mal projektspezifisch zwei Wochen da gewesen
und habe dort in deren Büro gearbeitet.
Mal live zusammen und nicht über GoToMeeting mit Zeitverschiebung von acht Stunden
und ich habe keinen Bock mehr auf längere Meetings,
weil ich demnächst Feierabend habe und du hast keinen Bock mehr auf längere Meetings,
weil du gerade sechs Uhr früh bist bei dir und du gerade aufstehst oder so.
Es war schon ganz wichtig, den Leuten mal vor Ort zusammenzuarbeiten.
Auf jeden Fall, klar.
Es war ganz cool, auch diese amerikanischen Büros sind ziemlich cool.
Wir haben ja hier ein relativ deutsches Bürogebäude, wo du ganz viele kleine Räume hast,
wo ganz viele Teams drin sitzen und so viert in einem Raum.
Und dort hast du so ein riesiges Großraumbüro, wo ich dachte, oh Gott, Großraumbüros.
Ich habe ja auch Kuselgeschichten erzählt bekommen von deutschen Großraumbüros,
wo so in Reihe und Glied so große Tische stehen,
wo immer acht Leute oder zwölf Leute dran sitzen
und dann sind die einfach der Reihe nach so Lagerhallen gestapelt.
Da hat sich das ziemlich cool verlaufen.
Die hatten eine ziemlich coole Küche irgendwo drin.
Ich habe mich auch teilweise wirklich so ein bisschen verirrt,
weil es irgendwie so ein bisschen durcheinander ging.
Dann hast du ganz viele kleine Meetingräume gehabt.
Das war super cool.
Und irgendwie Tischtennisplatte und Billardtisch natürlich.
Und das war eigentlich ganz nice.
Was mich ein bisschen irritiert hat,
ist, dass sie irgendwie nicht nur eine rauschende Klimaanlage an der Decke hatten,
dann auch so Noise-Generatoren. Die hatten
richtig so gleichmäßig verteilt an der Decke
so Lautsprecher hängen, wo so weißes
Rauschen rauskam. So ein bisschen wie
das hier.
Was wahrscheinlich auch
von Nick wegschneidet.
Das war gut.
Nee, das war ganz cool.
Und wo ich einmal
da drüben war, hab ich dann gesagt, wisst ihr was, wenn ihr mir
hier den Flug von da nach da macht,
dann macht mir doch mal den Flug von
da, von Dresden nach
dorthin. Und dann aber von ganz woanders
zurück. Dann habe ich quasi noch eine Woche
Urlaub hinten dran gehängt.
Stark.
Habe mir noch zwei Nächte bei einem Kuppel
auf dem Sofa gepennt und dann habe ich mir
ein kleines Auto gemietet,
weil ich nach San Francisco hochfahren wollte
und mich da ein bisschen umschauen wollte.
Habe ich irgendwie zwei Tage vorher
bei Mietwagen billiger oder billiger
Mietwagen irgendwie da so mir für
150 Euro oder 180 Euro
einen Ford Fiesta
geschossen.
Das war ein Wanchika-Ford-Fiesta, oder?
war ein Chica Hort Fiesta, ich kann da nämlich an
und die hatten
da eh bloß von Avis
irgendwie 10 Autos stehen und
kein Ford Fiesta dabei, ich hab halt
einen Ford Mustang gekriegt.
Ja, das ist eigentlich das, was man sich vorstellt,
wenn man Fiesta bucht.
Da war ganz schön Fiesta an dem Ding drin.
Das war auch ziemlich cool, weil Hauptattraktion
von dem Ausflug war, dass ich hier
Highway 1 von Santa Barbara nach
San Francisco mal hochfahre
und das sind 100 Meilen links Ozean,
Rechts Berge, so Serpentinstraßen und Aussicht.
Das ist auch schon ein gutes Auto dafür, da macht das auch Spaß, so ein Roadtrip dann.
Genau, und ich bin dann irgendwie den einen Tag 650 Kilometer am Stück da gen Norden gefahren.
Und weil es so geil war, bin ich zwei Tage später einfach nochmal 300 Kilometer wieder nach unten und 300 Kilometer wieder hochgefahren.
Und bin dann nochmal an so einem Nationalpark gewesen, dann hab ich tot umgeraucht. Das war ziemlich cool.
Hab ich ein bisschen im Silicon Valley umgeguckt und mal hier angeguckt, wie die Büros von Google und Apple so aussehen.
aber kommst natürlich nicht rein, wenn du nicht irgendwie einen guten Grund dafür hast.
Leider.
Ja genau, sonst habe ich mich ein bisschen in San Francisco umgeguckt.
Schicke Stadt?
Schicke Stadt auf jeden Fall.
Wesentlich größer als auf den Google Maps Top-Down-Ansichten wirkt.
Also wenn du dir die Google Maps Karten anguckst, denkst du dir so, ich bin ja hier, das ist irgendwo zwischen Golden Gate Park und, wie heißt dieser Park da am Norden?
Presidio?
kann ich ja mal zur Golden Gate Bridge latschen.
Im Endeffekt bin ich anderthalb Stunden gelatscht,
bis ich dann dort war, aber es war auch ganz gut.
Ich mache so ein bisschen laufen. War ganz schön.
Auf jeden Fall.
Dafür kann man das schön überall lang ubern
oder lüften. Genau, das habe ich auch
die meiste Zeit gemacht. Das hat super funktioniert.
Klickst du dir das Ding und dann steht da,
kommt innerhalb von zwei Minuten
und dann hält der direkt bei dir vom Laden.
Einen Abend war ich in der Stadt.
Du hattest mir irgendwie empfohlen, geh nicht in diesen
und jeden Stadtteil.
Und einen Abend habe ich mir noch empfehlen lassen von meinem
Airbnb-Verbieter, ich würde gerne
in so einen Jazzclub gehen, irgendwie was Cooles.
Ja, hier geht ins Black Hat. Und dann bin ich mit dem Bus
dahin gefahren und habe schon gedacht, warte mal,
ich gucke mal auf der Karte. Ja, das ist der Stadtteil,
von dem mich Kilian gewahrt hat.
Hier hocken schon ganz schön viele Obdachlose
auf der Straße.
Das war aber jetzt nicht so groß, da kannst du auch dran vorbeilaufen.
Die sind ja auch nicht gefährlich. Es ist halt bloß, du merkst halt
schon, wie
krass die Schere zwischen Arm und Reichen
Ja, das ist halt echt erschreckend teilweise.
Du gehst halt an 10 Obdachlosen vorbei auf dem Weg vom Bus zu dieser Kneipe und da drin denkst du dir, oh fuck, hätte ich mir mal irgendwie einen Sakko angezogen oder sowas, weil die Leute da richtig schick unterwegs sind.
Okay, krass.
Und dann, ja, war ich da ein bisschen drin, hab mir irgendwie zwei Bands angeguckt und dann hab ich mir gedacht, nun geb ich mir das jetzt hier wieder rauszulaufen.
bevor ich die Treppe aufgegangen bin, habe ich mir nach Uber
geholt, geklickt
und bevor ich dann auf der Straße
war, stand das quasi schon vor der Tür, weil
die Wartezeiten, gerade nachts
und in der Gegend waren halt unter
drei Minuten, zwei Minuten und
witzigerweise sind die Uber-Preise
nachts innerhalb der Stadt
dann auch billiger, also ich bin
tagsüber einmal gefahren
da habe ich irgendwie 15 Dollar bezahlt
und dann
nachts, als ich mich da rausfahren lassen, habe ich bloß
11 Dollar bezahlt oder so.
Okay, das ist schon gefühlt viel.
Also als ich zur WWDC da war,
also wir sind die ganze Zeit überall nur rum
geliftet oder gejubert
und das war, also ich habe meistens dieses,
die haben beide so ein Angebot,
wo du mit irgendeiner random
anderen Person zusammen bist, die in die ähnliche
Richtung möchte und die das quasi teilst.
Das habe ich nie ausprobiert.
Aber es ist super billig gewesen.
Also da hast du dann, keine Ahnung,
3 Dollar gezahlt für eine Streckequertstadt.
Also es war echt am Ende der Woche, wo wir wirklich überall hingefahren sind mit diesen beiden Services.
Überall?
Oh Gott, da habe ich vielleicht, keine Ahnung, insgesamt 60, 70 Dollar gezahlt dafür insgesamt.
Und das war gut.
Gerade da hast du natürlich auch die eine Party bei Lyft selber beim Rausgehen, keine Ahnung.
Im Nachhinein rausgefahren, das wurde der CTO von Lyft, den wir dann so ein bisschen angebettelt haben.
Von wegen, hey, wie sah es denn aus? Kostet sofort nach Hause.
Da hast du so einen Gutschein rausgerückt.
War ein bisschen komisch.
Brückblick.
Habt ihr dann den Fahrer wenigstens noch getippt oder sowas?
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr.
Konnte man das über die App machen? Weiß ich nicht.
Über die App kannst du das machen mittlerweile.
Ich glaube, dann war das dementsprechend.
Aber ich weiß auch nicht mehr.
Ein Traum, einen kleinen Wunsch, den ich mir noch selber erfüllt habe,
war, als ich den einen Tag von einem
etwas längeren Trip zurückkam.
Da bin ich, glaube ich, so ein bisschen durch Silicon Valley
einfach mit dem Auto gefahren.
War ich so kurz vor sechs
wieder in meinem Zimmer, in meinem Airbnb.
Ich frage mich, ob diese Woche, wo ich in San Francisco bin,
dieses Bay Area Rust Meetup ist.
Dann gucke ich da so drauf und schaue bei, wo man das mal gucken kann,
air.mozilla.org und sehe,
erster Eintrag, Bay Area Rust Meetup Livestream.
Und ich denke mir so, nein.
Dann habe ich so eine Minute überlegt, gucke ich mir das an,
lasse ich es sein, ich bin schon ganz schön kaputt.
Aber ich beiße mir einen Arsch, wenn ich in der Stadt bin und da nicht hinfahre.
Da habe ich mir ein Uber geklickt, das war auch innerhalb von drei Minuten da.
Bin ich mit dem Uber einmal da die quälige Stadt dort hingefahren.
Dann bin ich irgendwie vielleicht eine halbe Stunde später gewesen.
Dann lief noch der erste Vortrag.
Und war ziemlich cool.
Da habe ich ein paar Leute dort getroffen.
Sehr, sehr cool.
War ziemlich nice, ja.
Man sieht mich, glaube ich, auch ganz zum Schluss.
Da habe ich eine dumme Frage gestellt.
Da bin ich im Stream aufgetaucht.
Dann hat mich der Linus, ist ein Bekannter von mir aus Schweden, den ich auch...
Ach, der vom Kongress, oder?
Ja, dieser grünhaarige Schweder.
Der hat mich dann plötzlich über Signal angeschrieben.
Du sagst mal, bist du in San Francisco? Ich hab dich in dem Video gesehen.
Ist ja geil.
Ah, there is proof.
Super cool.
Das gefällt mir.
Ich hab auch mein Namensbatch, das ich mir da aufgeklebt hab, wo Marzilla drauf steht, immer noch hier auf meinem Laptop kleben.
Ja, unten drunter siehst du jetzt gar nicht.
Auf der Unterseite vom Laptop?
Ja, weil hier ja schon so viel aufkleben warst.
Ja, gut. So viel dazu.
Any other programming language related news?
dahinter und Umsetzungsvorschläge,
aber die grundsätzliche Idee
ist quasi Rust-like
Ownership Declarations oder quasi eine Art
Lifetime Specifier
mit ranzupacken an manche Dinge
oder dass du auch sehr explizit sein kannst,
wenn du eine Funktion deklarierst, dass du halt mit
sagst, ob der Parameter jetzt
geborrowed ist oder ob der
unborrowed, kannst du explizit mit
ranzchreiben, so wie wir letztens mit unserem
Zwift mal ein bisschen rumgespaßt hatten,
dass du mit dem Escaping oder Non-Escaping
Closures machen kannst.
Wir hatten uns kurz zusammengesetzt und ich habe mit deiner Hilfe
eine kleine iOS-App geschrieben.
Ich muss sagen, das mit dem Escaping habe ich
bis heute nicht gerafft. Das ist nicht so relevant, aber
auf dieselbe Art und Weise kannst du da ja,
könntest du möglicherweise
in den zukünftigen Sulf-Versionen da
drauf eingehen, ob Dinge gemoved
werden in Funktionen rein und dann nicht mehr
zugänglich sind und quasi so ein bisschen
Rust-like das Ownership-Modell mit aufziehst
und dem Compiler sehr viel hilfst dabei zu verstehen,
wie das Ownership
generell transferiert wird und da Dinge
zu optimieren dementsprechend und möglicherweise
auch, also Swift macht das ja, soweit ich
aktuell das gesehen habe, in den letzten
WWDC-Talks,
generell schon, dass zum einen zu Compile-Time
dich bei manchen Sachen drauf hinweist, von wegen, das hier ist
nicht so clever und manchmal auch zu Runtime,
wo der Warnings sind wir auf den X-Code, von wegen,
hey, hier machst du Dinge, die
hast du da reingegeben, dieses Ownership, das
willst du hier eigentlich nicht mehr mutaten.
Das wirft bei mir die automatische
Frage auf. Ich dachte, Swift
ist eine
Automatic Reference Counting
Garbage Collected
Ne, Reference Counted, nicht Garbage Collected
Ja, also quasi
ist das nicht genau das gleiche Modell
wie in
Python auch?
Dass du quasi auf jedes Objekt erstmal einen Reference Count
hast? Ich weiß gar nicht, wie Python das macht,
Speicher ist es dann in irgendeiner
Arena wahrscheinlich allokiert oder sowas?
Hast du da ein bisschen Einblick?
Also prinzipiell Reference Counted in dem Sinne,
dass, oh jetzt kriegen wir bestimmt böse
E-Mails.
Was mich hauptsächlich interessieren würde,
wie ist denn so die
Semantik von Objekten in
Swift allgemein? Es gibt ja
bei C++ hast du bei den meisten Objekten
Copy-Semantik per default und wenn
du Move-Semantik haben möchtest, musst du halt hier Standard
abschreiben.
Wenn ich jetzt
x gleich 5 schreibe und dann y
gleich x, ist das
dann eine Kopie, 5 ist irgendwie ein dummes
Beispiel, weil es eine Zahl ist, aber wenn es ein Objekt ist,
Wird per default erstmal kopiert oder wird meistens gemoved?
Ich dachte, es wird dann meistens einfach hier, quasi ist alles ein Pointer und dann wird die Referenz hochgezählt.
Also es ist quasi ein Copy.
Das hängt in Swift sehr davon ab, was du tust.
Also wenn du Reference-Types benutzt, im Sinne von Klassenobjekte durch die Kante schiebst,
dann sind das References und du gibst die Referenz weiter und es wird auch dementsprechend dieselbe Referenz weiter,
also beziehungsweise dasselbe Objekt dann weitergereicht.
Die muss ich dann explizit kopieren.
Wenn du eine Kopie haben möchtest, musst du es explizit kopieren.
bei Value Types, also ein Struct oder ein Inam
ist es genau anders, da wird
eine Kopie angelegt, aber die Kopie
wird erst beim Write angelegt
das Copy and Write alles
das heißt, wenn du erstmal das mit deinem 5 Beispiel
gerade auf ein Struct umziehst, in Swift passiert
dann aktuell noch überhaupt nichts, wenn du es woanders
hin assigns, erst wenn du das andere
da quasi irgendwas mutatest oder
sonst was mit tust, dann wird erst eine Kopie
angelegt in dem Moment, das ist
prinzipiell die Idee, wie Swift das macht
ansonsten, klar, alles ist
Reference-Counted in Swift, das heißt, alles hat
einen Reference-Count und wenn
der Reference-Count auf Null fällt, also nirgendwo
meine Referenz auf ein Objekt besteht, dann wird
das dialogated.
Das ist so die Grundidee.
Das heißt, wenn die jetzt so ein Ownership-Modell einführen,
würden sie quasi versuchen,
in den meisten Stellen erstmal... Insofern
ich das verstanden habe, wird das erstmal
nur für Optimierung benutzt
und für Warnings
zu Compile und zu Runtime, so wie es aktuell
schon so ein bisschen existiert tatsächlich, was sehr
cool ist. Und das einfach noch mit ein bisschen
weiter ausgebaut. Ich bin nicht der,
ich glaube nicht daran, dass Swift irgendwann
weggeht von dem, oder zumindest in absehbarer
Zeit von der generellen
Modell des Reference Counting. Das ist
zu sehr, zu weit tief da drin.
Möglicherweise, das wurde mal von der Zeit
angesprochen, könnte es andere,
also quasi, dass du Swift in einem
in einem anderen Kontext
dann benutzt, dass du es halt genauso,
nur mit dem, aufgrund, dass du das, nehmen wir es mal,
BorrowChecker dann damit hast und keine
Reference Counting und keine Garbage Collection dahinter stehen hast.
Das könnte sein, dass sowas irgendwann kommt,
aber gerade für Apple-Plattformen
ist Reference-Counting einfach zu fest
dafür sind sie doch, was das angeht,
schon längst viel zu opinionated in die Richtung.
Vielleicht, das ist halt immer die Frage,
aber
vielleicht wäre das ganz schön, wenn man dann verschiedene Kontexte hätte,
in denen man das Ganze ausführen könnte.
Ich habe jetzt immer noch eine Hausaufgabe für dich,
für die Shownotes, nämlich eine Podcast-Empfehlung,
ich weiß nicht, den hörst du wahrscheinlich auch,
den Swift Unwrapped Podcast, und da haben sie sich
neulich tatsächlich mit zwei von den Kernentwicklern
von Swift unterhalten,
Und eines der Konzepte, was ich bei Swift eigentlich ziemlich interessant finde, ist, dass die ihre ABI langsam stabilisieren und spezifizieren.
Das ist Pflicht für das Release von Swift 5. Swift 5 wird nicht rauskommen, bevor die ABI stable ist.
Genau.
Weil sie das Goal ein bisschen aufgeschoben haben.
Und das ist ja was, was andere Sprachen einfach nicht machen.
Also das ist nicht umsonst die C-ABI, die Lingua Franca für unterschiedliche Programmiersprachen.
Weil einfach die Sprachen ständig mal ihre, oder zumindest nicht versprechen, dass sie eine stabile ABI haben. Rust hat keine stabile ABI. Aber was ich bei der Swift ABI, wie sie es in diesem Podcast, das ist glaube ich Folge 2 von dieser Doppelfolge, erklärt haben, was ich interessant finde, ist, dass sie das gesamte Typsystem zur Runtime in Swift beibehalten wollen, also quasi Typinformationen, was zum Beispiel bei Rust komplett wegkompiliert wird.
Wenn du komplexe Typen hast, siehst du davon zur Laufzeit nichts mehr.
Bei Swift ist es so, dass du zur Laufzeit immer noch nachvollziehen können sollst, was Reflection zum Beispiel ermöglichen soll.
Das Ding war, eine Instanz von der Klasse mit dem Typ-Parameter oder dieser Funktionsaufruf ist tatsächlich diese Überladung von dieser Funktion mit den Parametern.
Und wie sie es machen, wie sie diese Informationen da annotieren, auf möglichst platzsparsame Weise, ist, dass sie das Mangeling dafür missbrauchen.
Dass sie quasi den Namen davon, dass sie quasi fast die komplette Typinformationen...
Nicht fast die komplette, sondern wirklich alles kommt in den gemangelten Name mit rein.
Und das finde ich ziemlich krass.
Das ist cool auf jeden Fall.
Das ist für uninvolvierte Leute schwer lesbar, aber wenn du da ein bisschen mal die Documentation so anschaust,
du kannst aus dem gemangelten Swift-Name wirklich
alles rausziehen. Da steckt
keine Ahnung, auch in Funktionsaufrufen,
jeder Swift hat ja Name-Parameters in Funktion,
jeder Parameter-Name, der komplette Typ,
alles steckt im gemangelten Name
drin. Ich finde es eigentlich ganz cool, das da mit reinzupacken.
Ja, ich meine, das macht Sinn,
im Endeffekt könntest du da auch fast die
Original-Syntax, quasi einfach bloß die Original-Syntax
ein bisschen anders encoded.
Im Endeffekt ist ja auch eigentlich nur ein Workaround
für die Tatsache, dass du da irgendwie
das halt eindeutig ansprechen möchtest.
Falls ihr jetzt als Zuhörer euch
fragt, wovon reden die da überhaupt? Ich begebe mich mal
wieder aufs Glatteis, weil ich eigentlich nicht so der
C++ Experte bin, aber es ist
oder es ist bei C++
zum Beispiel so, dass wahrscheinlich ist es auch bei
CSO, das ist ja das, was ich gerade mit Glatteis meinte.
Dass wenn du
wenn du
deinen Quelltext kompilierst,
dann hast du hinterher in deinem
Kompilat...
Sag nicht das Wort!
Dann hast du hinterher
in deinem kompilierten Code
deine Symbolnamen rumliegen, das heißt, du kannst zum Beispiel
mal probieren, ihr könnt zum Beispiel mal probieren,
mit dem Tool auf Linux
Strings
irgendeine
kopilierte C++ Binary
anzugucken und dann seht ihr so eine Liste
von seltsamen Symbolen, das sind dann
die ganzen Objekte und Funktionen
die Strings, die sind dann noch als Strings drin,
damit man die nämlich von außen, wenn man diese
Library linked, adressieren kann.
Und weil
diese Sprachen
überladen von Funktionen erlauben und dementsprechend
drei Funktionen den gleichen Namen haben können,
aber potenziell unterschiedliche Parameteraufrufe
werden die da irgendwie reingemängelt.
Da sind in C++ auch schon sehr viele Informationen drin,
aber bei Swift machen sie halt wirklich,
da legen sie extrem Wert drauf, dass sie da irgendwie
gesamte Typinformationen zu sowas damit reinpacken.
Das finde ich ziemlich krass. Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Wo wir gerade über Programmiersprachen
reden, es gibt natürlich
keine Akronomisierbarfolge ohne
nicht die Programmiersprache der Woche.
Sollte auch ein Segment
von uns sein. Das ist wahrscheinlich bereits ein Segment,
so ein U-Boot-Segment, von dem wir noch gar nicht wissen,
dass wir es eh jedes Mal besprechen.
Ich habe einen coolen Tipp bekommen, nämlich auch
von Jupp und von einem Kollegen
da drüben, als ich auf
Dienstreise war, nämlich die Programmiersprache
Reason.
Und dann sind mir immer
als sich witzig gefallen,
I'm a big fan of Reason,
the programming language, not the concept.
Well, the concept too.
Have you heard of the concept?
Have you tried using
Reason?
Was ist Reason?
Reason ist
keine neue Programmiersprache, sondern
einfach eine
neue Syntax für eine alte Programmiersprache
und zwar OCaml.
Aha. Und das
findet ihr auf
reasonml.github.io
Das ist ein
wie gesagt, das ist ein Facebook-Projekt
und das ist eigentlich ziemlich cool. Und was
die gemacht haben ist, die nehmen den
sogenannten BuckleScript-Compiler,
den findet ihr auf bucklescript.github.io
und der kompiliert
OCaml zu JavaScript
und
was Reason
quasi ist, ist OCaml
mit einer bisschen schöneren Syntax,
weil die OCaml-Syntax ist so ein bisschen abgefahren.
Aber die nehmen den normalen
OCaml-Compiler oder haben die den geforkt dafür?
Da gehe ich noch
drauf ein, die benutzen schon den
normalen OCaml-Compiler.
Ihr könnt euch mal
dieses Tutorial durchlesen und ich habe mir
ich habe versucht, was damit zu programmieren.
Ich bin dann relativ bald gescheitert, weil
so richtig die Usability von dem
Compiler und von der Toolchain ist noch nicht so wirklich da.
Es ist alles ein bisschen exotisch.
So richtig aufgeregt habe ich mich
darüber, dass die
Parameter, du hast einen Compiler,
der heißt BSB, das ist sowieso ein paar Sachen
mit BS genamespaced, finde ich sehr witzig
für Bugglescript. Und wenn du ein neues
Projekt erzeugst, machst du BSB
dash init, also mit einem
Strich.
Da hatte ich erstmal so eine visceral Reaction drauf.
Und dann gibt es aber ein cooles Feature,
was ich daran allerdings schick fand,
ist, dass du dann, wenn du ein neues Projekt erzeugst,
das ist halt wie Cargo New
oder NPM Init oder sowas,
kannst du unterschiedliche Themes angeben
und dann erzeugst du unterschiedliche Projektlayouten,
je nachdem, was du damit konkret machen möchtest.
Du kannst nämlich zum Beispiel auch,
es gibt einen Port von React
zu Reason. Du kannst also ein Reason React
Projekt bauen.
Was eigentlich ziemlich cool ist.
Und ich habe nicht geschaut, wie, aber du kannst Reason sowohl nativ, weil es halt OCaml ist, als auch nach JavaScript kompilieren.
Und das ist eigentlich relativ vielversprechend.
Angeblich ist dieser, der Facebook Messenger ist in Reason geschrieben.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der...
Also auf Messenger.com das Ding oder was?
Ja, genau. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Android-App da mitgeschrieben ist.
Es ist zumindest, so wie es momentan aussieht, nicht möglich, die gleiche Codebase nach JavaScript und nach Nativ zu kompilieren.
Ich glaube, da wollen die noch hin.
Aber ich gehe mal ein bisschen auf die Sprache ein.
Mir sind so ein paar Sachen aufgefallen, als ich mir durchgelesen habe.
Okay, das ist also jetzt hier OCaml mit einer anderen Syntax.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Aber nochmal ganz kurz zurück, wenn du meinst, du nutzt den OCaml-Compiler.
Heißt das, was ich in Reason schreibe, könnte ich auch einfach...
Du könntest es auch in OCaml schreiben.
Die benutzen einfach Syntax-Features von OCaml, um quasi ein eigenes Substit einer Sprache zu definieren, oder was?
Nee, die benutzen halt gerade nicht die Syntax von OCaml.
Die benutzen die Semantik und die Sprache selber, aber die Syntax haben sie leicht angepasst.
Du hast hier so Sprachbeispiele, wenn du mehrere Let-Variablen-Deklarationen hast,
dann würdest du die in OCaml in so einer komischen mit in verbinden
und dann so komisch eingerückt schreiben.
Und da haben sie sich hier gedacht, nee, wir machen mal eine etwas konventionellere Syntax.
Wir nehmen geschweifte Klammern, wir nehmen Semikolons.
Und es sieht also, wenn du Rust machst oder Swift, sieht das schon sehr gewohnt aus hier.
Du hast ein LED-Binding, du hast Algebra-Statentypen, du hast Pattern-Matching.
Das Match-Keyword sieht fast genauso aus wie in Rust.
Apropos Rust
in der Reason-Seite,
unter What and Why steht die Überschrift
Don't like Reason und dann ist unter anderem
gelistet Rust, Closed Cousin of Our House,
Not Garbage Collected, Focused on Speed and Safety
und ganz unten auch Swift, Fruit Flavored
OCaml. Ich will das Swift jetzt nicht als
Apples OCaml bezeichnen.
Fruit Flavored.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, ich habe mir diese Seite durchgelesen
und habe mir gedacht, okay, wenn das OCaml ist, dann, ich wollte mir
schon immer mal wirklich OCaml angucken und war meistens
so ein bisschen von der Syntax abgeschreckt.
Und dann schaust du dir das an, okay, das ist OCaml,
bin einer etwas konventionelleren
oder C-schaueren Syntax.
Und ich stelle fest,
Rust ist einfach
bloß OCaml. Also es ist
einfach bloß ein ML.
Und das ist eigentlich auch der Trick, wie sie Leute
rumgekriegt haben. Es ist eigentlich ein ML,
bloß, dass es dir nicht
direkt sagen. Und dass
es halt aussieht wie C oder C++
von der Syntax her. Und so ähnlich ist jetzt Swift,
äh, Quatsch, so ähnlich ist jetzt Reason
auch. Das fand ich halt ziemlich schick.
gerade halt, dass du so Konzepte
wie algebraische Datentypen und Pattern Matching hast
oder
du hast Funktionen und da musst du
keinen Return schreiben und sowas, das finde ich super schön
Was habe ich noch?
Es erzeugt
ML-Derivate, das ist eine schöne Sprache
Ja, auf jeden Fall, das ist alles
eine sehr unterschätzte Sprachfamilie
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass sie unterschätzt ist
Naja, sagen wir es so
Du hörst jetzt nicht ständig
davon, die Leute drehen
Du hörst nicht auch von ML, aber du hörst von
Ja, aber wenn du dich mal
wirklich zu Unterleuten umhörst, die Leute benutzen
Ruby und Python und JavaScript
und C++ und dann
Go und Swift
jetzt auch und Java ganz, ganz
viel, aber von ML hörst du wenig Leute.
Der ML hörst du gar nicht.
Das ist schon auf jeden Fall.
Und dann denken sie sich, das gab es vor 100 Jahren mal.
Und dann guckst du die Webseite von OCaml an
und dann siehst du einen Kamel und denkst an Pearl
und denkst dir so...
Du siehst das Kamel
und bist direkt töndorf.
Genau, genau. Und das ist hier bei Reason, auch der Name ist ganz schön, eigentlich ganz cool. Also es gab so auch so ein paar Sachen, wo ich mir gedacht habe, also was sie nicht richtig machen, ist irgendwie Capitalization von Sachen. Also Typen werden erstmal per se klein geschrieben, dafür werden Module groß geschrieben, das finde ich irgendwie falsch.
Es gibt auch kein Function Keyword, es gibt einfach immer nur die Lambda-Syntax wie in JavaScript.
Das heißt, wenn du eine neue Funktion deklarierst, dann schreibst du einfach
Kunst Funktionsname ist gleich Klammer auf Pfeil geschweifte Klammern.
Ich will ihm das überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Meinetwegen.
Also ich finde auch bei JavaScript gibt es ja so einen Streit, ob du das Function Keyword nehmen willst oder nicht.
Oder ob du einfach Kunst Function name ist gleich und dann in Lambda schreibst.
Ich muss sagen, ich benutze immer noch gerne das Function-Keyword.
Erstens, weil es dir besser ins Auge sticht,
weil du es besser von einfachen Variablen unterscheiden kannst.
Und zum anderen werden Functions im Gegensatz zu Kunstvariablen
in JavaScript nach oben gehäustet.
Das heißt, die sind schon benutzbar, bevor du sie deklariert hast.
Du musst sie nicht irgendwie...
Stimmt. Das ist ein großer Vorteil.
Ja, das macht es halt beim Benutzen ganz schön.
Das ist das beste Argument, was ich gehört habe.
was das dafür spricht, auf jeden Fall.
Apropos ganz kurz,
weißt du, wovor das ML
steht?
Für
Meta-Language.
Schön, dass es sehr viele Derivate dieser
Metasprache gibt.
Was ja auch ein cooles Konzept ist.
Das ist ein bisschen wie bei
Lisp. Da gibt es ja auch mehrere
Inkarnationen.
ML basiert auch auf Lisp und has been characterized
as Lisp-Types.
Naja, ist nicht so weit weg. Also ich habe auch keine Ahnung von Lisp.
Vielleicht schaue ich mir das als nächstes Mal an.
Also was ich nicht schön finde, ist, dass es kein Function-Cubord gibt.
Die haben auch so eine Generics-Annotation, die völlig falsch ist.
Nämlich benutzen sie ein Hochkomma und dann einen Kleinbuchstaben für Generics,
anstatt in spitze Klammern einen Großbuchstaben zu schreiben.
Wenn du schon sagst, wir machen hier eine Syntax, die ein bisschen vertrauter ist,
dann machen wir das doch einfach so.
Das sieht nicht schön aus, wenn ich.
Wenn du das nach JavaScript
kompilierst, hast du dann natürlich
Exceptions.
Und du hast zum Beispiel, glaube ich, keine
Lazy-Iteratoren. Das ist auch
so ein Konzept, wo ich mir denke, ah, wenn es so
wie Rust sein soll, dann hätte ich gerne sowas. Das finde ich geil.
Genau.
Und was halt hinterher bei herauskommt, ist noch,
wenn ich es jetzt mit TypeScript vergleichen würde,
TypeScript ist halt einfach bloß JavaScript mit Typen.
Und wenn ich es kompiliere,
dann werden die Typen gecheckt.
Und dann werden die ganzen Typer-Annotationen
weggemacht und vielleicht wird mal
noch ein aktuelles
JavaScript-Feature, wenn du als Target irgendwie
ES5 oder sowas angibst, wird irgendwie umkompiliert
in was mit dem älteren Standard funktioniert.
Aber ansonsten
bleibt es das Gleiche.
Und dadurch, dass die hier einmal
einen Okaml-Compiler
drüberjagen und einen AST aufbauen
und dann hinterher was Equivalent ist
in JavaScript ausspucken, ist es halt schon so,
dass das, was hinterher herauskommt,
nicht mehr wirklich wie das aussieht, was du mal in
in Reason geschrieben hast, auch wenn du dir
mögegibst, es möglichst ähnlich zu machen.
Was allerdings auch Vorteile hat, also da kommen halt
Objekte bei raus und Klassen, die
tatsächlich auch leicht gewichtiger sind, als das,
was du in JavaScript schreiben würdest.
Und das ist eigentlich ziemlich cool.
Ich finde es cool, dass es Named Arguments
gibt, zumindest optional.
Anscheinend sehe ich gerade, ich mag
Named Arguments und Function Calls, das ist so
eins der Lieblingsfeatures.
Das ist dieses Untergangs zwar ein bisschen komisch, weil du vor
jeden Namen ein Tilde packst, aber
Ja, ja, die Leute
also ich weiß nicht, ob es cool ist, dass Leute
kreativ sind, wenn man sich neue Syntaxen ausdenkt,
aber... Syntaxen?
Syntaxen.
Auch String-Konkatenation
wird mit plus plus gemacht.
Du schreibst
Hello-Lehrzeichen als String
plus plus Name in dieser
Hello-World-Funktion, in dieser Greet-Funktion.
Syntaxen ist tatsächlich der Plur von
Syntax. Ja, klar.
Fuck, das klingt so falsch.
Aber okay.
Stimmt, wenn ich hier Named-Parameter
sind...
Ah, das lese ich jetzt nicht vor. Also schaut euch mal
Reason an. Aber prinzipiell die Idee auf jeden Fall ganz cool,
dass es existiert. Genau, also das Tooling ist
wie gesagt noch
horrend. Du installierst dir das
über NPM. Ist das noch recht neu
eigentlich? Vielleicht, weiß ich nicht.
Die werden da schon eine Weile daran arbeiten.
Aber du installierst das erstmal über NPM und wenn
du dann Bild aufrufst, dann
läuft da Ninja
los. Aha, auf Ninja-Base
ist das okay. Naja, das Bildsystem, was
dann da mitgeht. Und dann guckst du erstmal
in deinen Node-Moduls, was ja normalerweise
eh schon riesig ist, aber das ganze
BuckleScript-Compiler und Reason-
unter Modul da drin sind
bereits da mehrere hundert Megabyte,
weil sie halt den kompletten Compiler-Toolchain
mitbringen. Also es ist halt
wirklich nicht gerade leichtgewichtig. Also da würde ich
eher empfehlen, das anderweitig zu installieren.
Das ist ja 2016, wenn es
laut GitHub rumgedockt wird.
Klar, es ist ein cooles Konzept. Also
irgendwann mal in der Firma von TypeScript weggehen,
dann gehen wir vielleicht zu Reason.
Witzig, interessant.
Ist das die zweite Programmiersprache
von Facebook nach Hack?
Ach, was war denn Hack nochmal?
Hack war dieser PHP-Forg von
der compilete, typisierte...
Ist PHP typisiert?
Nee, PHP ist nicht typisiert.
Okay, ich habe zu wenig PHP in meinem Leben.
Das ist nicht falsch.
Hast du gerade gesagt, zu wenig PHP?
Zu wenig, habe ich Erfahrung.
Ich kann nie zu wenig PHP in seinem Leben gemacht haben.
Okay, es typisiert und kompiliert
das Hack.
Eigentlich ganz witzig, dass das existiert.
Ja, Typisierung ist auf jeden Fall was.
Jetzt wiederhole ich mich wieder. Das habe ich bestimmt auch in fünf
anderen Podcast-Folgen gemacht. Kann ich nur unterstützen.
Typisierung ist auf jeden Fall was,
was du machen möchtest, wenn du mehr als 100 Zeilen
gut schreibst. Types sind was Tolles.
Types sind toll.
Okay.
Vielleicht hätten wir echt
von Anfang an darüber nachdenken sollen, dass wir hier
eigentlich einen Podcast über Typisierung
Programmiersprachen.
Ja, vielleicht. Mit dem gelegentlichen
Rant über andere Themen.
Apropos typisierte Programmiersprachen.
Darf ich ableiten?
Oder bist du noch bei Reason?
Nee, also das war jetzt eigentlich, Reason schaut
es euch mal an. Ich finde es eigentlich ziemlich cool. Ich hoffe, dass
sich das noch ein bisschen entwickelt und
ich habe darüber
mal wieder etwas über OCaml und auch
über Rust gelernt. Cool, cool. Ich bin sehr froh.
OCaml kann man sich auch mal geben.
Würde ich auch gerne mal wieder anschauen.
Ich bin bisher ein bisschen rumgespielt. Aber apropos
Programmiersprachen. Ich habe die letzten
vier Wochen,
fast, also jetzt ist es eine halbe Woche her
und eine Woche her, aber ich habe die letzten vier Wochen davor
ein Projekt an der
Fakultät Informatik an der TU hier
mit betreut, das RoboLab
oder RoboLab oder wie auch immer,
wo Erstis mit so Lego-Robotern
die autonom durch so
ein, sagen wir mal in Anführungsstrichen, Labyrinth
fahren und ihren Weg da
Linien folgen, Kreuzungen erkennen,
die abscannen und dann
die Story dahinter ist, es ist ein Rover
auf dem Mars und der fährt da rum und kommuniziert
mit dem Motorschiff-Server und
sagt, wo er langgefahren ist, muss irgendwie
Modometrie-Daten sammeln, damit er denkt, wo er...
Oh Gott, die geben dem jetzt schon eine richtige Geschichte.
Das ist krass gewachsen.
Ich habe das auch nochmal mitgemacht,
das sind diese Mindstorm-Roboter.
Im Endeffekt haben die einen Ultraschallsensor
und die haben einen Helligkeitssensor,
mit dem sie halt in der Lage sind, auf dem Blatt Papier
in der schwarzen Linie zu erkennen.
Also es geht
mittlerweile schon echt weit. Also die haben da so
Siehst du das RGB-Farbsensor,
den du nutzt, um der Linie zu folgen, weil du bist ja auch,
Kreuzungen sind rot und blau.
Also bei uns war das auch so,
natürlich, du
stehst auf der Linie, an der rechten Kante von der Linie,
ist schwarz, fährst du mit dem linken Rad,
siehst du weiß, fährst du mit dem rechten Rad
und dann wackelst du halt an der Kante von der Linie lang.
So haben wir das damals gemacht,
als ich das Projekt 2013 mitgemacht habe.
Keine Ahnung, warum du das gemacht hast.
Aktuell sollen die halt da
so einen PID-Controller schreiben,
also einen PID-Regler.
Und da halt wirklich aufgrund der Grau-Werte, die Sie sehen, wird ja immer grauer, also immer grauer, Bullshit, immer heller, je weiter du von der Linie runterkommst.
Dementsprechend halt mit dem anderen Rad entgegensteuern.
Und da kannst du echt richtig smooth auf der Mitte der Linie langfahren.
Also als wir das gemacht hatten, hatten wir noch so einen schwenkbaren Kopf, der regelmäßig diese Linie abtastet.
Das war viel zu komplex.
Ja, das haben drei Minuten.
Und da gab es unterschiedliche Lösungen.
Entweder du weißt, wie weit dein Messkopf ausgelenkt ist und richtest dich dann danach aus, was wie gesagt viel zu komplex ist.
oder du schaust einfach,
ich fahre immer auf der rechten Seite dieser Kante lang.
Das haben wir auch nicht die bestehen.
Das heißt, wenn die Kante auf einmal,
wenn es plötzlich weiß ist,
muss ich nach links
und wenn es komplett schwarz ist,
dann muss ich nach rechts,
was auch ein anderes Problem hat,
weil wenn du plötzlich links aus Versehen drüber bist,
dann drehst du dich im Kreis
und fährst die gleiche Linie zurück.
Du kannst auch, glaube ich, nicht über Kreuzungen,
weil du immer nur rechts abbiegen kannst.
Und irgendwer hat da dann noch was gebaut.
Ich meine, du brauchst irgendwie eine Heuristik
wenn Kreuzungen oder Kurven kommen.
Jemand hatte was gebaut, der wirklich anhand
der Helligkeit gemerkt hat, okay,
das ist jetzt meine Optimalhelligkeit, die hast du
am Anfang so eingestellt. Wenn es heller
wird, dann muss ich halt leicht in die Richtung
und wenn es dunkler wird, muss ich leicht in die Richtung
korrigieren. Das ist eigentlich ziemlich cool.
Auf jeden Fall. Aber wie gesagt, das ist echt
sogar ziemlich krass, was manche Leute
von den Erstis oder teilweise sind das ja auch nicht
Informatik-Erstis. Das sind auch teilweise
ihr Stela, also
Informationssystemtechnik.
Genau, Informationssystemtechnik heißt der Studiengang, das ist ein Elektrotechniker, quasi mit dem, also der Studiengang, wie gesagt, Informationssystemtechnik, Fakultät ET und noch Physiker im höheren Semester, die das Projekt mitmachen.
Da kommen schon teilweise echt krasse Lösungen raus. Also wir hatten eine Gruppe Physiker, die hatten auch den Farbsensor perfekt auf die Achse zwischen den Rädern gepackt und dann kannst du halt auf der Kreuzung, haben sie eine krasse Drehung hingelegt und plötzlich war das eine Rad auf der Mitte der Kreuzung und dann fährst du mit dem anderen Rad einfach einen Kreis drumherum,
hast die Kreuzung perfekt durchgescadet,
sah fantastisch aus.
Das ist, glaube ich, auch die optimalste Lösung,
die du machen kannst.
Wenn du den Sensor genau auf der Achse der Räder hast,
dann hast du die beste Kontrolle.
Genau.
Und Hindernisse sollten du noch erkennen,
du hast gerade Ultraschallsensor gesagt,
im Prinzip haben wir meistens das mit dem Tast-Sensor gemacht,
gegen so eine Flasche fahren
und dann zurücksetzen und wieder zurückfahren
und da halt melden, dass die Strecke blockiert ist,
weil, was haben wir, glaube ich, gesagt,
ein Meteoriteneinschlag oder irgendwas,
war der Storygrund dafür?
Also ich habe echt lange überlegt,
weil sich das Zeug ja auch immer wiederholt
und es jetzt nicht schwierig ist,
irgendwie vom Vorjahr sich von irgendjemand anders
den Code für so ein Gerät zu besorgen.
Ich finde es cool, dass sie jetzt langsam
solche Geschichten dafür erfinden.
Also es gibt auch jedes Jahr Änderungen,
explizit dafür, dass die halt nicht den Code übernehmen
von anderen Gruppen oder von Bekannten.
Genau, da gibt es auf jeden Fall Änderungen dafür,
um Plagiaten vorzubeugen.
Das heißt nicht, dass das nicht aus dem passiert.
Also dass Leute Plagiaten versuchen und dabei auffliegen
und lächerlich, passiert immer wieder, leider.
Aber worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte,
ist, die machen das Ganze in Python.
Und das ist ziemlich cool und ich habe kurz davor
auch ein bisschen so meine Liebe für Python wiederentdeckt
und habe ziemlich viel in Python gemacht so die letzten
Wochen, aber irgendwann reicht es einfach
dann wieder. Was wir witzig machen in dem
Robola-Projekt, dass wir dieses Typing-Module nutzen,
wo du in Python
auch sehr typisierte,
sagen wir mal,
Datentypen, also im Sinne von, du kannst angeben,
du willst eine Liste mit dem Inhalt,
dem Typ-Inhalt haben
oder ein Tuple, was genau aus
zwei Ints und einem weiteren Tuple und noch was
besteht oder Dictionaries,
mit vorgegebenen Key- und Value-Types
und kann es halt sowas genau angeben. Und so haben wir
quasi den, was die haben zum Template
bekommen, wo wir quasi die API, die wir
haben wollten, damit wir deren Code auch testen
können. Zumindest die einzelnen Bestandteile.
Im Prinzip gab es da so viele Bauteile.
Einmal die Farbenmechanik, die können wir schlecht testen. Das sehen wir nur,
wenn der Robot tatsächlich fährt. Dann gab es
einmal, dass sie diese
Planeten irgendwie als Datenbank
speichern, in dem Sinne von, welche Pfade
existieren und
Pfade hinzufügen und diesen shortest path eben
berechnen, ob die das jetzt mit einem Dijkstra machen oder was auch
sei dahingestellt. Da gab es natürlich
eine vorgegebene API, das können wir im Prinzip gut testen.
Diese Server-Communication
war wunderschön spezifiziert,
wie die mit unserem
Server da über so ein MQTT-Protokoll reden.
Das hat wunderbar funktioniert
und was war das Letzte?
Ich habe mir gerade gar nicht mehr einen. Egal,
sei dahingestellt. Aber
ich fand das ganz cool, das mit dem
Typing-Python-Modul
zu machen und da viel vorzugeben
und blöderweise
hier lernt man nicht nur Python, sondern versucht gleich mal euch anzuschauen,
wie typisch das Python ausschaut, weil das findet
ihr nirgends online. Also natürlich
findet man die Documentation dazu, aber das macht
halt, niemand schreibt sowas und wenn du
also schade eigentlich nur.
Wenn du halt anfängst irgendwo
Python Standard Tuple zu mischen mit den
Tuple Types, die aus dem Typing
Modus kommen, die Syntax dafür ist auch absolut schrecklich.
Du definierst dann Tuple, eckige Klammer auf
und sag dann was quasi,
keine Ahnung, Tuple, großgeschrieben
Tuple, eckige Klammer auf, int,
int, klein, eckige Klammer zu.
Das heißt, die Syntax, um zu spät zu finden, dass du ein Tuple aus
Veränden schon haben möchtest, ist ein Typing-Tuple.
Nicht das Python-Standard-Tuple, sondern ein Typing-Tuple.
Und wenn du anfängst, das zu mischen,
dann wird das sehr unterschiedlich.
Und ist das zur Laufzeit noch da?
Wird das zur Laufzeit evaluiert?
Python ist ja generell, aber das ist zur Laufzeit evaluiert.
Es gibt ja keinen...
Okay, es gibt also keinen Pre-Processor, der da drüber geht
und schaut, dass du das sinnvoll machst.
Ich meine, das Crashed-to-Runtime,
an der Stelle, wenn es passiert, wenn du da Mist machst,
wenn es überhaupt crasht.
Ich glaube, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das eine
Das ist ja Schrott eben. Also du kannst ja in Python 3
auch schon Funktionsparameter
typisieren. Du kannst ja sagen,
hier Funktionsparameter foo ist ein
Integer. Und wenn du jemanden in den String reingibst
oder mit dem String aufrufst, dann kriegt
dir Python zu der Runtime an der Stelle wirklich,
ich weiß, ich bin gerade nicht mehr sicher, ob eine Exception fliegt.
Ich glaube, es ist eine Exception mit einem Type Error tatsächlich.
Kannst du schon was machen.
Also das ist schon ganz cool, dass das geht. Du kannst in Python 3
auch Rückgabetypen spezifizieren. Die sind in Python,
das ist relativ egal. In Python 2 ist das
ein Sünderungsfehler, also genauso wie in Swift mit so einem
Pfeil dahinter, halt machst.
Das ist ein Zunächst-Fehler in Python-Tribe.
Also der evaluiert schon zur Laufzeit, ob du ihm die
richtigen Sachen reingibst, wenn du das als
Parameter-Typen oder als Argument-Typen
definierst. Das geht ohne das Typing-Module, das hat mit dem
Typing-Module überhaupt nichts zu tun. Das Typing-Module
ist, um dann die Datenstrukturen zu typisieren.
Aber die Rückgabewerte evaluiert er nicht?
Nö, das ist Python-egal. Das ist eigentlich schade.
Das kommt vielleicht noch in
weiteren Versionen von Python. Wenn du eine IDE
wie PyChamp-Type benutzt, der versteht das sehr wohl
und der hat einen Eilert, der sagt,
sagst du, das Ding gibt irgendwas zurück und du
returnst überhaupt nicht explizit. Das ist ja auch erstaunlicherweise,
wenn du sowas wie WebStorm hast, funktioniert das auch
für JavaScript ziemlich gut. Das finde ich schön.
Ich habe gerade übelst Lust, unsere Zuhörer mit Syntax
im Audioformat zu quälen.
Weil du nämlich gerade gesagt hast,
dass hier die Syntax für einen Typen
von einem Tupel in Python
sieht aus wie ein Tupel selber.
Wenn du in
TypeScript hinschreibst,
Klammer auf, Klammer zu, rund und dann
File, also fetter File und dann geschweifte Klammer auf,
Klammer zu. Das ist ja eigentlich
JavaScript in Lambda.
Das ist ein leeres Lambda, was nichts tut.
Das ist aber in JavaScript gleichzeitig
die Syntax für einen
Funktionstypen. Nämlich,
ich habe keinen Parameter und dann
habe ich einen Pfeil
und was ich zurückgebe, ist dann der Typ,
der auf der rechten Seite von dem Pfeil steht.
Da steht dann geschweifte Klammer auf, geschweifte Klammer zu,
heißt leeres Objekt.
Das heißt,
diese Syntax beschreibt sowohl
ein Lambda als auch
einen Typen und das Lambda erfüllt
diesen Typen selber nicht. Das ist
komisch.
Schreib mal ein Lambda hin
in JavaScript, was ein leeres Objekt
zurückgibt. Da musst du zweimal
in geschweifte Klammern ineinander schachteln.
Und das fällt mir
eigentlich nur ein, weil ich heute mal wieder
in der Verlegenheit war, ein bisschen
C++ zu schreiben. Da haben wir uns gedacht,
haben wir gepaart, Paired Programming gemacht.
Und da haben wir überlegt, ach hier, für
den Scheiß, das schreiben wir jetzt ja nicht fünfmal hin, da machen wir
mal ein kleines Lambda.
Aber warte mal, das müssen wir
quasi irgendwie typisieren,
wie gehen denn getemplatete
Lambdas? Kam im Endeffekt raus, brauchst du nicht
templaten, kannst du einfach mit Auto schreiben, aber
wir haben dann in der Speck gelesen,
ah, es gibt getemplatete Lambdas
dann in C++20
und die Lambda-Syntax
in C++ ist jetzt schon eklig.
Du schreibst nämlich drei Sorten
Klammern hintereinander für ein leeres Lambda.
Du schreibst eckige Klammer,
runde Klammer, geschweifte Klammer
auf und zu.
Und das erste ist in der eckigen Klammern ist, was es
captured, was ich cool finde, weil du
explizit capturst.
Dann die runden Klammern sind die Parameter
und die geschweiften Klammern
sind dann der Body.
Und in C++20 kannst du schreiben
runde Klammern,
äh, äh, äh, äh, äh.
Eckige Klammern,
spitze Klammern, runde Klammern,
geschweifte Klammern.
Das ist dann ein Typ-Parameter.
Ah, ach so.
Du kannst es noch templaten.
Oh Gott.
Du kannst zum Beispiel schreiben,
eckige Klammern und, um Sachen per Referenz,
in den Score per Referenz zu capturen,
Spitze Klammer auf, Glas, T,
Spitze Klammer zu, Runde Klammern,
dann irgendwas, was du damit tatsächlich machst.
Fucking C++, ey.
Immer wieder schaffen die eins zu überraschen,
wie viel Komplexität man in sowas reinschieben kann.
Also diese Sprache ja generell,
ich meine, das haben wir oft gesagt,
jedes Feature generell schlucken möchte,
was es gibt in jeder anderen Sprache.
Was ja viele andere Sprachen auch machen.
Nee, ich meine, das an der Stelle immer dahingestellt.
Was mich immer wieder wundert,
dass bei jeder Designentscheidung, die sie treffen,
irgendwie die falsche Richtung einschlagen ist.
Dass du zum Beispiel bei Sachen,
die keine Exception werfen,
No Accept dran schreiben kannst,
anstatt bei Sachen, die Exceptions werfen,
Accept dran schreibst.
Und wenn das No Accept ist,
wenn da No Accept dran steht,
dann ist es nicht mal garantiert,
dass es auch wirklich keine Exception schmeißt.
Oder dass du Sachen Kunst machst und die dann halt immutable sind. Na gut, das kannst du nicht machen, das ist halt backward compatible gewesen. Ansonsten hättest du gesagt, mach doch einfach alles Kunst und schreib irgendwie nicht Kunst dran, wenn es nicht Kunst dran sein muss.
Oder dass du explizit Overwrite an Überladung von Funktionen schreibst, damit der auch schaut, dass du da wirklich gerade versuchst, was zu überschreiben, was es vielleicht schon gibt. Und wenn du Overwrite an was schreibst, was es nicht gibt, dann beschwert er sich dann.
Gut, das machst du bitte mal auch so.
Ja, das ist
so nett, die das nicht anders
machen können.
Wahrscheinlich gibt es da bessere Gründe, als ich gerade
nennen kann.
Wir werden Hate Mail bekommen.
Ja, sowas von... Also Jupp alleine wird mir jetzt
bereits schon drei sagen.
Er textet schon.
Ja, da haben wir doch heute eine richtig schöne
Programmiersprache-Folge gehabt.
Das ist so wunderbar.
Dann kommen wir doch zu anderen Empfehlungen
jetzt mal. Hast du Picks?
Ich habe was gepickt.
Also nicht, dass wir nicht die ganze Zeit schon Sachen
empfehlen, nämlich das Heskel-Buch
und Reason und Snips.
Also Snips muss ich mir echt nochmal angucken.
Und was hast du noch
aufgezählt? Also wir haben eigentlich, eigentlich ist es ein
Pick-Cast. Prinzipiell machen wir das.
Aber kommen wir mal zu dem
noch unstrukturierteren Teil.
Du meinst der beststrukturierteste
Teil? Unsere paar GitHub-Stars
der Woche. Genau, GitHub-Stars der Woche.
Ich habe mir ein Projekt rausgesucht,
das ist ein witzig kleines Python-Script, was
diese neue API
von dem
Have I Been Pawned Typen nutzt,
um deine Passwörter zu checken,
ob die schon mal in einem
Leak aufgetaucht sind
und nutzt dieses coole
K-Anonymity Model.
Finde ich ganz cool, dass du da
quasi natürlich nicht dein Passwort an diese
API schickst und schaust, hey, ist es drin oder nicht?
Das wisst ihr eigentlich nicht, sondern dass du
was in SHA-1-Herrsch davon machst
und die ersten fünf Zeichen davon
hinschickst und du kriegst dann dementsprechend
Antwort zurück, ob
welche Hashes das übereintrifft.
Du kriegst eine Liste von
matchenden Hashes. Genau, und dann kannst du selber
evaluieren, ob das da komplett mit drin
checkt, ob der Hash. Informationstheoretisch
ist das ganz gut.
Das heißt, der Web-Splorer hat einfach überhaupt keine Ahnung,
was du eigentlich für Daten haben möchtest,
was für eine Passworte du das haben möchtest.
Und da habe ich einen kleinen Skript gefunden, was das
quasi mit allen Passwörtern aus meinem
Password-Manager-of-Choice, OnePassword,
macht. In meinem Fall waren es glaube ich
1100 Einträge, die ich mittlerweile über die Jahre
gesammelt habe. Oh ja, du generierst ja echt für alles
ein neues Random-Pack. Ich mag auch gerne
neue Accounts pro Service
und nicht geshared über, keine Ahnung,
sonst wie Social Login. Ich mag das überhaupt
nicht.
Und hat das mal durchgejagt
und tatsächlich habe ich nur
mit drei Passwörtern,
das waren meine alten Standard-Passwörter, die ich mal
für Dinge benutzt habe, von einer Reihe von
Services, wo das noch drinsteckt, anscheinend laut Passwort-Manager,
wo von 80% nicht mehr
mehr leben, wo er dann halt dementsprechend
die gefunden hat, dass die das Passwort
das braucht. Wie gesagt, drei verschiedene Passwörter,
die alle schon mal in irgendeinem Breach mit drin waren, aber
fand ich cool und das Skript funktioniert echt gut.
Gibt dem Ende CSV mit hier, der Service,
Porn, yes, no.
Geil, geil.
Gefällt mir. Also ich freue mich jetzt schon darauf, wenn du es
in die Show Notes getan hast, dann gucke ich mir das mal an.
Was mir da eilt, was, was,
sag nochmal? One Pass Porn
Check. Heißt das, ist nicht so
clever, aber.
Dazu Related fällt mir gerade ein,
also wenn ihr mal auf dem Kongress
mal zu dem Stand von
vom
Föhrbutt, wie heißt denn jetzt?
Digitalkourage.
Die haben da wie so eine
Enzyklopädie rumliegen.
Die
häufigsten Passwörter, so in
vier oder fünf Bänden, also
von A bis Z, da kannst du drin rumblättern
und da stehen halt ganz viele Passwörter, die Leute
verwenden. Da habe ich manchmal drin rumgeblättert,
ob ich da meine Passwörter sehe, aber das ist halt
wie gesagt alphabetisch, da musst du dann aufpassen, dass dir nicht
über die Schulter guckt und so
guckt, in welche Richtung du grob schaust.
Ist auch nicht schlecht.
Genau, und ein anderes, was mir noch aufgefallen ist,
ist, dass Mozilla
gerade selber
an so einem
Passwort Management Service arbeitet,
der in Firefox dann landen soll.
Der heißt Logbox.
Okay.
mozilla-logbox.github.io
Habe ich mir noch nicht genau
angeguckt, ist auch glaube ich noch relativ
früh in der Entwicklung.
aber
das fände ich eigentlich cool, wenn die sowas bauen.
Muss ich mir mal anschauen.
Was ich ja vor allem cool finde, ist, dass die auf dieser Seite bereits
die haben jetzt angefangen,
die haben jetzt so eine Suite an kleinen Cartoon-Charakteren,
die überall auftauchen,
die auf diversen Fehlerseiten auftauchen,
bei, keine Ahnung, Zertifikatsfehler
oder 404 oder Offline oder sowas.
Und für diese Lockbox
haben sie auch schon so einen kleinen
Cartoon und das ist ein Nessie.
Was mich ein bisschen ärgert,
das fällt mir jetzt bei der Gelegenheit auch ein,
kann das sein, dass
Firefox dieses About-Doppelpunkt
abgeschafft hat? Keine Ahnung.
Du konntest mal About-Doppelpunkt eingeben
und dann hast du quasi gesehen, welche Firefox-Version
du hast und wie der User-Agent-String
ist einfach das, was du kriegst, wenn du normalerweise
bei hier auf Hilfe
oder über Firefox.
Das gab es auf jeden Fall mal.
Das gibt es jetzt nicht mehr, da kommt jetzt
That address doesn't look right
mit so einem Cartoon.
Ist das ein Bug, dass der irgendwie aus Versehen
der URL-Parser in der
Unbox-Rom-Miss macht?
Dazu fällt mir noch ein, es gab auch noch
so ein cooles Plugin, das finde ich gerade
nicht mehr. Das neue Mozilla-Logo
ist ja moz.doppelpunkt
slash slash a Mozilla
und es gibt auch ein Plugin für Firefox, was
dir erlaubt, mods.doppelpunkt
slash URLs einzutippen.
Ich dachte, das sollte ein Feature von Firefox werden.
Ist das so ein Add-on dafür? Ne, das gibt's als Add-on.
Gab's nicht mal ein offenes Issue?
im Boxilla für, dass das
unterstützt werden soll.
Leite dich weiter zum
blog.mozilla.org
slash open design
Das kann aber daran liegen, dass ich vielleicht
dieses Ding installiert habe. Das müsstest du mal bei dir probieren.
Anyway, währenddessen
erzähle ich mal von meinen
Picks.
Und zwar das erste
Pick, was ich habe,
mache ich einfach zwei kurze Picks draus, weil es
JavaScript-related ist. Das eine
heißt NeoDoc.
Leidet bei mir auch weiter,
nur so auf Open Design.
Ach, sehr schön.
Dann haben sie es tatsächlich eingebaut.
NeoDoc ist eine Empfehlung von Jup gewesen.
Wenn ihr Kommandozeilen-Tools
in JavaScript bauen wollt für Node.js,
dann probiert doch mal NeoDoc aus.
Und zwar ist die API folgende.
Du schreibst einfach den Wüffel-Text als String.
Der wird gepasst.
Oh, krass.
Und das kannst du dann verwenden.
Und das Schicke ist auch noch,
dass die eine Webseite haben,
wo sie es halt im Browser machen.
Da tippst du deinen Text ein,
beziehungsweise du kannst es, glaube ich, sogar generieren lassen.
Und dann wird dir dort visuell angezeigt,
was du daraus ziehen kannst.
Du musst noch zwei Schritte entfernt davon.
Du schreibst den Hilfetext,
dann wird dir die CLI komplett generiert von dem,
was du da hinschreibst, was du haben möchtest.
Das gibt es auch schon.
Also ich meine, da wird dir der Code auch mitgeschrieben.
Achso, achso, nee, nee, nee.
Aber der CLI-Parser wird dafür generiert.
Also in Rust gibt es das, glaube ich, als Makro.
Nee, das ist kein Makro, das ist schon zur Runtime noch.
aber hier gibt es auch
genau, da hast du halt diesen
String da drin, den musst du automatisch formatieren
oder kannst du irgendwie noch mit einer Formatierungshilfe
formatieren. Ist eigentlich eine schöne
API, vor allem weil du halt sofort die Hilfe hast.
Wir haben das für ein internes
Tool genommen, da hatten wir vorher ja Minimist,
das ist ein komplett minimaler, aber auch
dementsprechend bescheuert zu bedienender
Kommandozeilenparter und
Neodocker ist wesentlich schöner.
Du hast noch einen Pick. Ich hab noch einen Pick und zwar
muss ich dafür ein ganz kleines bisschen ausholen.
Es gibt eine krasse App
für iOS, die heißt Pythonista,
wie man das aussprechen möchte,
die dir einen Python-Interpreter
gibt und haufenweise
geile Packages, mit denen du direkt,
also das Ding hat sogar einen UI-Designer
eingebaut, du kannst deine Custom-UI
zusammenfrickeln und dann Skripte ausführen, du kannst die
in deine Extensions mit reinpacken,
diese Today-Extension-Skripte ausführen, du kannst
unglaublich viel mit dieser App machen,
das ist ein unglaublich geniales Teil,
ich weiß nicht, ich habe das schon ewig auf meiner Liste gehabt
und letztens erstmal gekauft, die kostet halt auch
10 Dollar oder 10 Euro, ist jetzt nicht
billigste App, aber die ist es auf jeden Fall wert.
Ich bin beeindruckt von dem, was man damit alles machen kann.
Und dann
gibt es, um dem Ganzen noch eins
draufzusetzen, ein Projekt namens Stash.
Und Stash ist
eine Shell für Pythonista.
Und es ist einfach, die haben quasi eine
minimale Shell in Python geschrieben,
die du da reinpacken kannst und plötzlich hast du
halt eine Shell vor dir in dieser
App und die ist halt komplett in Python
geschrieben und die haben da Standard-Unix-Tools
einfach neu implementiert in Python.
Natürlich nicht genau auf dieselbe Art und Weise,
das ist ein bisschen weird, aber es gibt natürlich
Dinge, die man von Thunderbolt erwartet
und kennt. Es gibt sogar ein SSH-Client,
den ich selber... Also, das ist
fucking beeindruckend.
Und ein eigenes Pip und du kannst damit einfach random Module
nachinstallieren, also zumindest die Dinge, die
pure Python sind, und einfach dann benutzen
innerhalb dieser App und das ist unglaublich
cool. Es macht echt Spaß.
Aber du möchtest dann eine Tastatur an dein
iPad anschließen, oder? Ja, ich hab's aktuell am iPhone
benutzt, das ist noch ein bisschen umständlicher.
Aber für minimale
ist das schon stark beeindruckend.
Macht auch am iPad echt Spaß.
Und Stash finde ich einfach nur mindblowing,
was die da gemacht haben. Das hat mich
ein bisschen überzeugt. Und auch ein eigenes Git
in Python geschrieben, was Standarddinge
von Git kann. Das ist natürlich kein
normales Git, aber...
Die werden wahrscheinlich irgendwie
Libgit mit Python-Bindings da reingebunden haben.
Ich weiß nicht inwiefern.
Das erinnert mich jetzt, also wenn du auf die
Webseite gehst, Python-Nista 3
für Python-IDI für iOS,
da muss ich immer an seine Freundin denken,
die im ASCII saß und
für ihren Nebenjob so ein bisschen PHP gemacht hat
und weil sie keinen anständigen Laptop
hatte zur Zeit, hat sie auf ihrem iPad
gekodet die ganze Zeit und der Workflow bei
PHP, der war ja, oder ist ja
immer noch so bei Web-Apps,
äh, write, save,
FTP-Upload,
meistens sogar auf dem Live-System
oder sowas und so hat die das auch gemacht,
die hatte glaube ich, die eine App war der Editor,
die andere App war der FTP-Client,
die dritte App, die sie hatte, war der
Browser, wo sie es dann immer mal neu geladen hat und so
die da auf dem Sofa, die ganze Zeit auf ihrem iPad
rumgetatscht.
Das würde mich wahnsinnig machen.
Nee, also im Robolab
war auch einer da, der kam am ersten Tag mit seinem
iPad in der Hand zu mir, Seite von App Store
und hat auf Python Insta gezeigt und meinte, kann ich das auch
benutzen? Mein Prinzipiell
klar, aber du wirst ganz bestimmt
Probleme haben, unser
Deploy-Skript für den Robo auszuführen
und Dinge einfach über LZB darüber
zu kopieren. Darf ich das auch benutzen?
Da würde ich mich auch fühlen
wie so ein angesprochener Lehrer. Darf ich das?
Nein, du darfst das nicht.
Das war prinzipiell alle Fragen. Es gab die mehreren Leute mit
Mitteilungsbedürfnis, die einfach nur die ganze Zeit ihre
drei Zeilen Code abgestempelt
bekommen wollten und sagen, hey, ist es okay,
ja gut, du musst nicht mit
allem zu mir kommen, es ist okay, mach einfach
mal und wenn es Probleme gibt, frag nach, aber
ansonsten, mach einfach mal.
Traurig. Genau, mach kaputt,
es ist doch gut, wenn es kaputt geht.
War vielleicht ein bisschen komisch, dass auf dem Roboter eine T-Max-Session
lief, da lief ein Debian
auf dem Roboter, mittlerweile sind die Dinger
hart, krass. Ja, klar.
Und darauf liefen wir Team Accession, die in Python
am Leben gehalten hat, weil Python-Staaten auf den Dingern
ewig gedauert hat und damit schneller geht,
haben wir diese Team Accession genutzt,
Python immer den Code reloaded,
hot reloaded und dann
Wie macht man das überhaupt in Python?
Mit dem Reloader-Module.
Und haben, genau,
und haben das genutzt.
Hat was zu sehr witzigen Bugs bei manchen Sachen
geführt hat, aber
ich fand immer wieder geil, wenn die Leute
herkamen und so für sie im Team Accession, ich kann nicht ja rumscrollen,
Ja, da muss natürlich das komplett intuitive Tastenkürzel,
STRG B, eckige Klammer auf auf der deutschen Tastatur tippen.
Und dann kannst du im Scroll-Mode
nach oben gehen. Also wenn mich mal jemand
vor einen Original-T-Max setzen würde, wäre ich
aufgeschmissen. Ich habe mir da irgendwann am Anfang mal
so ein paar Sachen angeguckt,
die ich sinnvoll fand und die habe ich mir auf
irgendwelche Tastenkombinationen gelegt, die teilweise
noch an Screen angelehnt sind.
So ein Scroll-Modus ist bei mir F7.
Ich kenne auch die Aussage
von Leuten, ich konfiguriere
mir sowas nicht, weil ich könnte ja irgendwann mal bei jemand
anders am Rechner sitzen und dann komme ich nicht klar.
Ich konfiguriere es minimal, sodass ich verstehe,
wenn ich online Dinge darüber lese.
Steuerung B habe ich auf Steuerung A gelegt, weil ich mir doch nicht meine Finger brechen möchte,
wenn ich T-Max nutze.
Stimmt, das ist weit weg.
Aber prinzipiell
versuche ich meine Configs für diverse Tools
immer auf einem Minimum zu halten.
Also wenn ich es verstehe,
generell nicht konfigurieren, weil ich es nicht verstehe,
aber versuche es minimal zu halten.
Also ein paar Kollegen von mir benutzen
Emacs
und die habe ich mittlerweile gebeten, wenn wir noch zusammenarbeiten,
Können Sie mir doch mal bitte ein Gäste-Wim installieren?
Der mit dem ich jetzt,
der an dem neuen Team, wo ich jetzt bin,
mit dem ich die letzten paar Tage zusammengearbeitet habe,
der ist richtig krass drauf gewesen.
Der musste für mich, damit ich bei ihm mit am Computer
arbeiten konnte,
eine Gäste-Tastatur anstecken
und das Layout umstellen,
weil er nämlich eine
zweigeteilte Tastatur,
die so in der Mitte durch ist und mit dem Kabel
verbunden ist, damit er die Hände gerade hinlegen kann
und hat da Dworak-Layout drauf.
es gibt tatsächlich Leute, die Dworak nutzen.
Ich dachte immer, entweder Standard,
keine Ahnung, US International oder
Neo, aber Dworak habe ich noch nie
im echten Leben gesehen. Doch, einmal.
Stimmt nicht. Einmal habe ich es gesehen.
Ich habe da mal von jemandem gehört,
der hat wohl Dworak benutzt.
Nee, ich habe jetzt tatsächlich einen im Team, der das macht.
Aber Neo ist doch viel sinnvoller als Dworak.
Lass uns diese Diskussion nicht starten.
Ich bin vor 15 Jahren
auf ein US-Layout umgestiegen und ich bin
damit sehr zufrieden.
US International all the way.
Ich habe noch
einen Pick
und zwar haben wir ja, der würde dich bestimmt
auch interessieren, den habe ich von jemandem empfohlen
bekommen auf diesem Rust
Meetup, nämlich dem ersten Typen, der diesen Vortrag gehalten
hat. Oh, von dem hatte ich
schon mal ein Stück Code als Pick übrigens
beziehungsweise. Also wenn ihr euch das
aus dem
März
das Rust Bay Area
Meetup Video auf
r.mozilla.org anguckt, der Typ, der den ersten Vortrag
er redet über
Algorithms in Rust und
er stellt eine ganze Menge Crates vor.
Und er selber hat
dieses Syntect-Crate geschrieben,
was quasi Syntax-Highlighting
mit Sublime-Regeln
macht.
Das kann also diese Sublime-Language-Syntax-Spezifikationen lesen
und damit zum Beispiel
er hat ein Syn-Cut gebaut,
was quasi gesyntax-highlighted
in Source-Code cutten kann.
Cool.
Und der arbeitet, glaube ich, gerade
macht ein Praktikum und arbeitet mit
Raph Levine zusammen.
Und der arbeitet, glaube ich,
an Sonntagshighlighting für den
XAI-Editor.
Sehr, sehr cool.
Davon total unabhängig. Der hat also einen Vortrag über ganz viele
Crate gehalten.
Und der auch erzählt, naja, ich musste meine ganzen GitHub-Stars ja mal
da wieder durchsuchen.
Ich hatte ja selber mal neulich, weil ich irgendjemandem was empfehlen
wollte, meine ganzen GitHub-Stars durchsucht.
Da habe ich dann irgendwann
ich eigentlich gesucht habe, auf Seite 23 oder
sowas gefunden. Man kann echt mal seine ganzen
GitHub-Stars wieder durchgucken und da sind so einige Perlen
dabei und bei mir ist das eh bloß so ein riesen
Stapel von Zeugs, wo ich
irgendwann mal auf Like klicke und mir denke,
das ist geil, das muss ich mir irgendwann mal in Ruhe angucken
und dann vergesse ich es wieder. Es gibt sogar extra Seiten, die
nur darauf ausgelegt sind, deine GitHub-Stars zu taggen
und zu super anzumachen.
Und eine davon ist Astral-App.
Ist das genau das gerade?
Die Astral-App.
Und das ist, du gehst auf astral-app.com,
logge sich da mit deinem GitHub-Account ein.
Das ist genau das, ja.
Du kannst dann automatisch deine GitHub-Stars
nach Programmiersprache taggen und du kannst
noch eigene Tags vorgeben und wenn du
auf ein Projekt klickst, kriegst du dann so die
Readme angezeigt und wie viele Stars
und Fox, das ist quasi so eine
andere Ansicht auf
GitHub, nur mit deinen Likes.
Witziges für die, die die Idee gerade hat,
damit du vorschadowst.
Ich habe ja das Problem
gerade lang genug beschrieben.
Da müsste man mal was für programmieren,
was deine GitHub-Stars sortiert.
Das ist also mein Star, GitHub-Star.
AstroApp.com
So, bevor du jetzt
in diese App reinstarst und dich freust
und dir hier Stille auftreten lassen in diesem Podcast,
das ist ja auch immer unangenehm
für Leute, die da zuhören.
Wollen wir es abrunden?
Können wir machen.
Gut, dann finden wir jetzt hier ein
wohldefiniertes Ende. Das war
Folge 16 von
Akronomisierbuch.
Runde im Podcast.
Vielen Dank für euer Feedback.
Wir haben diesmal Feedback
per E-Mail und per Signal erhalten.
Schreibt uns gerne weiter an
akronomisierbar.atfastmail.com
ist unsere E-Mail. Oder
schreibt uns direkt Messages
an atakronomisierbar auf
Twitter. Immer gerne.
Das bekomme ich dann zumindest auch eher mit,
weil ich glaube, diese Fasten-Werweiterleitung ist bei mir nie angekommen.
Ich habe es gefixt, das ging tatsächlich nicht.
Ich tue mir leid.
Mittlerweile geht es doch wirklich in uns bald.
Genau.
Das war Folge 16 und die nächste Folge
in eurem Podcatcher beginnt in
3, 2, 1.
Piep.